Pierre connaissa. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
succintement. Euh bon, c'est le il y a
que l'aspect professionnel qui intéresse
probablement les internautes. Moi, je
j'ai commencé par faire des études. J'ai
j'ai une une vie universitaire ératique.
J'ai commencé à faire des maths et puis
je me suis rendu compte que c'était pas
ça qui m'intéressait. J'ai fait de
l'histoire, j'ai passé une agrégation
d'histoire.
J'ai enseigné pendant 5 ans et puis
ensuite au bout de 5 ans, je
m'emmerdais. Donc j'ai présenté Lenna,
j'ai réussi à Lena.
Après les nage, j'ai été 5 ans juge
administratif, ce qui est une fonction
assez intéressante parce que c'est les
comment on juge les dysfonctions de
l'administration.
Et pareil au bout de 5 ans, je
m'emmerdais donc j'ai commencé à
changer. C'estàd je suis parti au
ministère de la défense où je suis resté
beaucoup plus longtemps. Toujours par
tranche de 5 ans parce que c'est à peu
près la durée de mon cycle d'emmerdement
5 ans et donc j'ai fait ça puis après je
suis parti sur les aides à la presse
puis après je suis revenu au ministère
de la défense. Enfin la défense, j'ai
fait tout sauf de l'administration
et en particulier, chose
particulièrement sulfureuse, j'ai fait
de l'exportation d'armement parce que ça
ça fait partie de ces sujets qui sont
des sujets dans lesquels on si tu veux,
on y reviendra. Et puis après, j'ai j'ai
été débauché par un copain qui avait
créé une boîte deintelligence
économique. Donc pendant 10 ans, j'ai
dirigé une boîte d'intelligence
économique dont j'ai que j'ai quitté
après pour aller vers la voie royale de
la retraite, là où [raclement de gorge]
je suis actuellement. profession stable
s'il en est maintenant puisque je pense
pas que je reviendrai dans le circuit
professionnel. Voilà donc c'est ça en
gros et maintenant j'écris quoi c'est
plutôt ça mon occupation.
Donc on a décidé de vous faire revenir
aujourd'hui pour un faire plaisir à la
communauté qui était restée sur sa fin
avec votre dernier passage ton dernier
passage il y a 3 mois où tu nous
annonçais la sortie de ton prochain
livre. Donc on en profite, c'est avant
l'été, on va se faire encore une part de
dessert avec Pierre Consa. On voudrait
parler de ton dernier bouquin. Comment
il s'appelle ?
Alors le dernier bouquin s'appelle
Vendre la guerre. Le vendre la guerre
le complexe militarauintellectuel.
Ça tombe bien, on est en plein dedans.
On est en plein dedans et surtout on
n'est pas dans la guerre. C'est ça le
plus extraordinaire. A des gens qui
veulent voudrait qu'on fasse la guerre.
C'est pour ça que le sujet me paraît un
sujet d'actualité.
C'est un peu une drôle de guerre. Donc
on va en profiter aujourd'hui pour
délayuer ce qu'on a pas pu délayer la
dernière fois.
On dit bonjour à toute la communauté, on
en profite. Première question, c'est
quoi une bonne technique pour vendre une
bonne guerre ? Il faut commencer par
quoi ? Bah, c'est-à-dire dans
l'histoire, il y a suffisamment
d'exemples, hein. Moi, j'avais commencé
en quittant mes fonctions dans les
affaires stratégiques, en écrivant un
bouquin qui s'appelle la fabrication de
l'ennemi.
Parce que euh la meilleure définition de
l'ennemi que j'ai trouvé, c'est la
définition de proches qui disaient
"L'ennemi est stupide parce qu'il croit
que l'ennemi c'est nous alors qu'en fait
l'ennemi c'est lui."
Et ça donne une idée assez précise du
manière dont ça fonctionne, c'est-à-dire
euh la différence entre une dictature et
une démocratie, c'est que dans une
dictature, si un jour le chef se lève et
qui dit "On va faire la guerre, on vair
le Kuwait, exemple vécu, il a évidemment
autour de lui des courtisans qui lui
disent "Oui, quelle bonne idée chef, on
aurait dû y penser avant chef." Bon,
dans une démocratie, c'est pas pareil.
Dans une démocratie, il faut que la
guerre doit être présentée comme
démocratique. C'est-à-dire qu'il faut
que l'opinion publique soit convaincue.
Et donc selon les circonstance
historique là cette fois on a
effectivement plusieurs types de
fabrication de l'ennemi. Alors par
exemple [raclement de gorge]
quand on est dans des conflits
territoriaux du genre récupérer l'Alsace
Laorine les faiseurs de guerre sont les
historiens, les géographes, les
juristes. Enfin explique, tu vois par
exemple Géographe avait inventé une
notion qui m'a toujours fait rêver,
c'est la frontière naturelle. Comme si
tu sais, il y avait un moment où Dieu
avait décidé qu'il y avait des
pointillers à tel endroit et que là ça
devait séparer de pays. Il y avait
d'autres qui qui disaient
[raclement de gorge] "Mais ça
historiquement cette terre est à nous."
Donc donc ça c'était le le cas le plus
simple. Dans les guerres de religion,
dans les guerres civiles par exemple, on
voit bien qu'il y a tout un certain
nombre de conjonctions qui sont des
intellectuels, qui sont des autorités
religieuses, qui sont des des pouvoirs
locaux qui vont expliquer que l'autre,
c'estàdire le voisin,
doit [raclement de gorge] être tué.
Alors, le principe de la guerre civile,
c'est qu'il vaut mieux le tuer vite
parce que sinon c'est lui qui risque de
te tuer, tu vois. Donc, c'est une guerre
sans front continu. Et donc ça c'était
la chose qui m'avait intéressé,
c'est-à-dire pourquoi est-ce qu'on
arrive à la guerre ? Et donc, j'ai
essayé de prendre plusieurs types de
guerres. Bon, tu vois bien que par
exemple dans la colonisation, on partait
d'un espèce de principe au 19e siècle
appuyé sur la révolution industrielle,
c'est queon avait trouvé le moyen de
faire progresser l'humanité et donc on
allait bénéf bénéficier un certain
nombre de pays de ces progrès de
l'humanité à part la colonisation par
exemple. Et donc on était convaincu
qu'effectivement et enfin moi je suis né
dans un pays de colonisé justement parce
que je suis n en Algérie.
On avait un discours qui consistait à
dire mais voyez finalement regardez tout
ce qu'on leur a apporté c'est des
ingrats quand ils ont commencé à se
révolter. On leur a apporté l'éducation,
on leur apporté la santé et cetera. Mais
tu vois que c'était un discours qui se
construisait en en métropole, qui était
répercuté évidemment par les les les
métropolitains qui vivaient sur place et
puis évidemment ça paraissait comme un
espèce de paradis en tout cas pour les
pour les les colons et puis évidemment
pour les coloniser bah ça c'était pas
aussi simple que ça. Donc tu vois on a
ces processus que qui m'ont intéressé
dans les démocraties parce qu'encore une
fois on est sur quelque chose où le la
guerre c'est une aversion de valeur.
C'estàd la guerre il faut tuer. Si tues
pas, tu es tué par tes compatriotes.
Donc il vaut mieux être convaincu en
particulier pour la pratique. Mais tu
vois que par exemple quand il y avait le
système de la guerre froide, on avait
deux systèmes colossaux face- à face
avec tous les mécanismes si vous voulez
pour démontrer que le mal c'était
l'autre et que nous on était le bien.
Bon donc c'est ça qui m'a intéressé et
évidemment après j'ai poursuivi cette
réflexion
sur différents aspects.
[raclement de gorge]
Là, évidemment, ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est surtout de faire apparaître ce
cette notion que j'ai que j'ai mis dans
la titulature, c'està-dire le complexe
militarointellectuel.
Pourquoi j'ai retenu cette ce concept ?
Parce que pendant toute la guerre
froide, on a fonctionné sur le discours
d'ener. Quand Eenware quitte son deuxème
mandat de président, il fait un discours
expliquant qu'il faut se méfier du
complexe militaire industriel
industriel. Et pourquoi ? Parce que il
est en pleine guerre froide. il se rend
compte qu'à peine de sortie de la
guerre, on a recommencé, on a recommencé
à faire des programmes d'armement et il
sentait lui à l'intérieur de la
démocratie qu'il y avait une
contribution de ses industriel à
l'augmentation des budgets de défense, à
la création de nouveaux programmes et
cetera. Bon et donc on a fonctionné
pendant toute la guerre froide sur cette
idée-là, c'est-à-dire que c'était les
industriels qui faisaient la guerre.
Bon, c'était repris d'ailleurs dans
Tintin et le chef d'autocar puisque
finalement on a le le personnage là, je
sais plus comment il s'appelait, Bazirof
qui se baladait avec sa sa valise avec
des des armes à vendre des deux côtés,
tu sais, dans la où c'est ou je crois
que c'était dans le SE d'autocar les les
spécialistes corrigeront. Donc tu vois,
on avait gardé cette idée qu'il y avait
des marchands d'armes qui se baladaient
sur la planète et qui allaient
entretenir des conflits.
Bon, avec la disparition de l'URSS, on a
basculé dans un nouveau système et c'est
pour ça que j'ai pensé que le meilleure
explication de ce qu'on vit depuis
91-92, la disparition de l'URSS, c'est
le complexe militaroint intellectuel.
Alors, c'est quoi le complexe
militaroint intellectuel ? Ça regroupe
qui ? Comment ça se passe ? Comment ça
arrive dans nos oreilles et dans nos
yeux ?
Le [raclement de gorge] processus est
une espèce de conséquence indirecte donc
de la disparition de l'UR RSS. La
disparition de l'URSS évidemment c'est
un choc gigantesque puisque l'ennemi qui
pendant 70 ans avait structuré toute la
pensée stratégique
disparaissait.
Le conseiller de Arbatov, le conseiller
de de Gorbatchev avait dit "On va vous
rendre le pire des services, on va vous
priver d'ennemis."
Et effectivement son raisonnement était
formidable puisque effectivement tout un
système stratégique à partir du moment
où il y a plus d'ennemis simplement
Arbatov s'était trompé sur quelque chose
c'est qu'il pensait que avec la
disparition du pack de Varsovie
on aurait la disparition de l'OTAN. Bon
il s'est un peu trompé sur le sujet mais
ça voulait dire qu'il était bien dans
l'idée que de toute façon la
déconstruction de l'ennemi devait
aboutir à des conséquences de paix. Il y
a eu des cas de déconstruction de
l'ennemi qui ont abouti à la paix. le
complexe franco-allemand si tu veux, la
réconciliation franco-allemande, c'était
après quatre guerres. Euh, il fallait
les hommes d'état comme Dog et Adoer
pour dire "C'est fini, on arrête le
match." Et c'est comme ça qu'on a
construit l'Europe. Tu sais que la
première fois que Degol a invité à Dener
pour commencer à parler du traité de
l'Élysée, il l'a invité à Colombé parce
qu'il s'est dit si je l'invite à Paris,
il va y avoir des manifes. Donc il a
préparé la chose. Il se rendait bien
compte et pourtant Dieu lui on pouvait
pas le soupçonner d'être un collabo.
Donc si le fait qu'il est senti la
nécessité de prendre ses précautions
montre combien les choses étaient encore
vives. Et sur cette réconciliation
franco-allemande, on va faire ensuite la
construction de l'Europe. Donc il y a
bien des processus sociologiques qui
sont intéressants à dépioter. On les
comprend bien quand est on est dans la
gare froide, quand on est dans la
construction de l'Europe et cetera. Mais
à partir de 91 donc on va avoir deux
évolutions significatives.
La première évidemment c'est que la
Russie ne met plus de droit de véto
puisque
quand il y a l'invasion de du Kit par
Saddam Hussein, on va commencer à en
faire une affaire internationale, l'ONU,
vo de l'ONU et cetera. Et donc les les
occidentaux vont obtenir le mandat de
l'ONU pour aller libérer le Kit. Grande
démocratie devant l'Éternel mais enfin
peu importe.
Et donc euh
ce ce séisme est intéressant parce que
euh
le les Saoudiens sentent la menace,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sentent que Saddam
Hussein à proximité, ça peut pas rester
comme ça. Et donc les les rois d'Arabie
Saoudite disent "Il nous faut un allié
qui soit capable de nous protéger."
Alors, il y a un certain Ben Laden qui a
beaucoup travaillé en Afghanistan avec
les Américains, qui a combattu les
Russes en Afghanistan, qui dit "Mais
nous, on va défendre nous combattants
musulmans boujahidin, on va défendre la
terre des lieux." Et les R disent
"Ouais, enfin c'est sympa mais enfin
parlons on parle entre gens sérieux."
Donc ils ont appelé les Américains et
l'arrivée des Américains, ça voulait
dire 150000 personnes qui ont débarqué
si tu veux de qui se sont installées
avec des femmes
pardon
des mécréants.
Des mécréants et puis surtout avec des
femmes en uniforme. Alors
ah bah oui parce que en fait si tu veux
des choses qui ont beaucoup choqué les
Saoudiens, c'est que quand tu avais une
femme en uniforme qui se voyait
vitupérer par un type de la police
religieuse et que si le type l'emmerdait
un peu, c'était lui qui prenait une
raclé. Donc tu avais tout un système
d'inversion de valeur à cause de cette
présence-là. le fait que les Américains
se comportaient évidemment comme des
troubles d'occupation, mais enfin c'est
des troubles d'occupation et de
libération et donc ça a été un grand
traumatisme pour l'Arabie Saoudite mais
enfin bref
donc tout le monde est là c'est-à-dire
qu'on sait qu'il va y avoir la guerre.
Il y a un ultimatum qui est délivré
Addam Hussein. Tu as 6 mois pour quitter
le Kit [raclement de gorge] donc pendant
6 mois
pendant 6 mois on va avoir une chaîne
d'info en continue. Nous c'était la 5
mais surtout c'est le triomphe de CNN.
On va avoir la
6 nous.
Ah c'était la 6 déjà ou c la 5 je sais
plus. C'est la 6.
Donc on va avoir tous les jours tous les
jours, tous les jours des reportages
pour dire voilà les troupes sont comme
c, les troupes sont comme ça et cetera.
C'est-à-dire qu'on commence à vivre la
guerre en live et donc on attend le
moment paroxistique où enfin va se
déclencher l'offensive.
Et en fait, manque de chance,
l'offensive en 120h, en termine avec
l'armée de sa dame. C'est-à-dire que
toutes les chaînes de télévision du
monde étaient là, elles attendaient une
guerre sérieuse. Or 120h, l'affaire est
bâchée. Deux conséquences de ce
phénomène. Bon, le premier c'est
qu'évidemment on se dit "Mais on a des
armées tellement supérieures à tout ce
qu'il y a sur la planète." Donc Saddam
Hussein c'était quand même présenté
comme la 4e armée de la planète. J'ai
jamais su qui était la 3e he donc me
pose pas la question, je sais pas. Mais
en tout cas, elle était classée 4e. Or
en 120h, on emballe l'armée iraakienne.
Donc c'est réglé. Et donc on
occidentaux, on se dit bah ça va
maintenant on a tué une une on a comment
dire anéanti une armée d'une dictature
du socialisme arabe. Ça c'est important
à comprendre. On a libéré un pays et
puis en plus on a une la guerre devient
un spectacle qu'on vit en live, qu'on
vit en direct.
Alors euh ces deux caractéristiques là
vont être extrêmement importantes parce
que évidemment à partir de 91, les
occidentaux vont se mandater
comme gendarme de la planète.
C'est-à-dire ils vont dire bon ben
puisqueon a les moyens militaires,
il faut intervenir. Et c'est là
qu'apparaît le complexe militaire
intellectuel puisque tu vois bien
qu'avec la disparition de l'URSS, les
soviétologues par exemple sont des gens
qu'on qu'on regarde plus, on les
interroge plus. d'ailleurs, pourquoi
donc s'interroger sur ce qui était la
soviétologie puisque ils sont plus
soviétiques, ils sont plus communistes
et par contre ils sont dans une crise
économique, sociale, politique
dramatique. Dramatique hein, vraiment
ils sont cononvertis pour la plupart non
? Ils sont poutinologues maintenant.
Alors non parce qu'il y a une longue
phase si tu veux de il y a une longue
phase où effectivement on leur posait
plus la question donc il y a eu une
crise existentielle des soviétologues.
Maintenant ils réapparaissent.
Maintenant, ils disent "Voyez, on avait
raison, on vous avait averti." Voyez
donc le très rapidement, on va donc
faire des interventions qui n'ont pas
une très grande signification
stratégique. C'est-à-dire qu'on va
utiliser des militaires en
interposition, seriez-vous ? On va
mettez-vous entre les deux trucs et vous
allez les séparer. Vous allez voir en
apparition en casque bleu, ils vont se
calmer. Ils sont pas calmés du tout. on
a quand même perdu une cinquantaine de
types et donc le mais la bonne
conscience était là. De la même façon
Somalie, on intervient en disant comment
c'est inadmissible que les chefs de
guerre pillent les convois humanitaires.
Enfin c'est scandaleux, la population
souffre et cetera. Donc on fait
l'opération où nous sommes avec les
Américains, avec les autres occidentaux
et cetera. Mais manque de chance, le
l'arrivée de l'aide humanitaire se fait
par le port de Mogadicio. Le chef de
guerre de Mogadicio, c'est le général
Aidid. Donc on dit celui-là il faut s'en
débarrasser. Bah il était plus coronit
puisque finalement il fait tomber un
hélicoptère américain dans une
embuscade. Il va y avoir une vingtaine
de types qui vont mourir.
Un film d'ailleurs. La chute du faucon
noir. C'est ça
la chute du faucon noir. Ils en ont fait
un film et donc
qui était un peu arrangé je crois bien.
Non
je sais pas je l'ai pas vu. Mais enfin
oui ça doit être arrangé à Hollywood. Je
veux dire c'est c'est un peu sa sa
mission. Mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que l'opinion publique se retourne
on dire mais est-ce que ça vaut la peine
de faire mourir des G pour ces types ?
Et donc à partir de ce momentl, les
Américains disent "Les Africains ils ont
qu démerdé quand on va monter
l'opération turquoise au Rwanda, les
Américains disent "Non, non, nous ça ne
nous concerne pas." Bon, donc tu vois
comment une opinion publique se retourne
si tu veux dans cette phase d'euphorie
qui était celle de la décennie 80 2000.
Nouvel épisode le 11 septembre. 11
septembre, c'est effectivement un choc
gigantesque puisque
c'est la première fois que les
Américains connaissent la guerre sur le
territoire, que cette guerre est filmée
en direct puisqu'on a tous suivi
l'écroulement des Twin Towers, tous. Et
donc, on se rend compte qu'il y a
quelque chose qui est en train de se
passer qui évidemment est un profond
choc traumatique pour les États-Unis.
Et il va donc se passer quelque chose
qui est assez intéressant justement pour
essayer de cadrer sur ce que ce complexe
militar intellectuel, c'est que pardon,
première chose, personne n'avait vu
arriver le le risque Ben Laden. Or quand
même, c'est un type qu'on avait aidé
battre combattre les Russes, il avait
râé à cause de la guerre du golfe et
cetera et cetera. Mais enfin, c'est pour
dire que le système n'est pas encore une
fois, malgré tous les moyens de
renseignement, n'est pas capable de tout
percevoir et de tout anticiper. Mais
à cause de l'importance du choc
psychologique que ça va représenter aux
États-Unis, va apparaître une nouvelle
strade de ce complexe
militarointellectuel qui s'appelle les
psi. Parce que face à un choc comme
celui-là, tu as deux solutions. Soit tu
te dis c'est de notre faute, pourquoi
nous ? Donc il faut s'interroger sur ce
qu'on a fait. Si l'autre solution c'est
de dire non mais on n pas à se poser
interrogeromme puisque nous sommes le
bien c'est donc que c'est l'autre qui
est le mal et donc il faut le qualifier
et donc on va commencer à faire ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui avec Poutine
c'est-à-dire mais en fait ce type il est
paranoïque psy schizophrène tout ce que
tu veux [raclement de gorge] parce que
il ne peut pas être normal et donc le
fait qu'il soit anormal suffit à
excuser.
Donc on est dans quelque chose où tu
vois que finalement les facteurs
d'explication n'ont plus rien à voir
avec une espèce de
d'analyse [raclement de gorge] froide de
la situation mais sur quelque chose où
chaque société va se trouver ses
explications pour justifier la guerre.
Et tu remarques que après ça
le 15 saoudien sur 19 terroristes,
on se dit ciel et ben George Bouche fait
en en janvier 2002 un discours disant
que c'est l'Iran, l'Irak et la Corée du
Nord, les axes du mal.
Alors moi, je me suis beaucoup posé la
question de savoir comment on avait
évité l'Arabie Saoudite
parce que quand même c'était tellement
évident.
Dès le 12 septembre, il y a une chaîne,
il y a une boîte de relation publique
américaine qui s'appelle Corvis qui
vient voir l'ambassade d'Arabie Saoudite
et dit "Vous savez, vos affaires, ça va
mal, vous avez tort de vous vous de
dédaigner les questions de relation
publique parce que là maintenant vous
êtes au cœur du cyclone
[raclement de gorge] et alors Corvis qui
va obtenir vite un contrat assez juteux
qui va se poursuivre encore pendant
assez longtemps et puis Corvis ayant été
racheté par publicist, on continue sur
le même sujet. Bref, Corvis va se
consacrer à essayer de jouer de son
influence sur le Congrès parce que le
Congrès est en train de faire un rapport
sur le 11 septembre. Le Congrès veut
comprendre. Bon, et on va réussir à se
obtenir ce résultat fantastique, c'est
qu'il y a 28 pages du rapport du Congrès
qui sont classé secret défense par
Georgio Bush. C'est que 28 pages n'étant
déclassifié que par Obama 14 ans plus
tard. Donc tu te dis il y a quand même
de l'efficacité dans le système. Or tu
vois que justement l'intérêt de la ligne
de communication de l'Arabie Saoudite
c'est qu'on ne parle pas de l'Arabie
Saoudite. Bon donc tu vois comment
fonctionne ce système où tu vas avoir
effectivement des boîtes de relation
publiques pour faire du travail qui vont
être de relations publiques, d'éviter
les questions, de contourner les
difficultés, de se trouver des des
portees-paroles et cetera.
Je te coupe.
Ouais vas-y.
Je me fais la voquer du diable. Mais il
faut aussi présenter un un regard
nouveau sur l'Arabie Saoudite.
C'est un peuple qui change. Maintenant,
les femmes peuvent conduire.
Je sais pas encore à qui complètement,
mais enfin oui, je comprends ce que tu
veux dire. Mais justement, ça va être
une conséquence de ça. C'est-à-dire que
là, ils se rendent compte
qu'effectivement c'est pas jouable.
C'està dire c'est plus possible d'être
dans cette espèce de dédain de l'opinion
publique internationale. D'autant que
[raclement de gorge] il va y avoir
quelques années plus tard l'affaire
Kachoui. C'est-à-dire l'affaire Kachogi,
on sait que le mec a été ça a été une
opération d'écarissage. Il a été découpé
en morceaux dans un consulat saoudien à
Istanbul. Bon
en musique ? Ah, je sais pas, j'ai pas
vu la version musicale. Ils en on fait
une comédie musicale. Le le mec avait
ses écouteurs. Euh
Ah oui. Et si tu veux, ce qui est très
intéressant, c'est que dans l'affaire
Kachogi,
les Turcs avaient sonorisé complètement
le le consulat.
C'est-à-dire que quand les la femme de
Kachogi qui était dehors commence à dire
"Mais mon mari où est-il passé ?" et
cetera. Le consulat dit "Non, non, il
est parti. Regardez d'ailleurs, il y a
des images, il partent et cera. Alors
Turc disent non, à ce moment-là non,
c'est pas lui. Et elle a dit mais si
mais si c'est lui. Ils disent non,
regardez, on reprend les images à
l'aéroport, c'est pas lui. Et donc
progressivement, les Turcs vont mettre
en difficulté l'Arabie Saoudite sur ce
sujet-là. Et donc à partir de ce
moment-là, on se rend compte
qu'effectivement l'arab enfin les
responsables arianes ne peuvent plus
rester dans cette espèce de de position
marmoréenne si tu veux où le les chiens
à bois la caravane passe quoi. Et donc
progressivement ils vont se rendre
compte que la communication moderne
c'est aussi s'adresser à des
spécialistes, c'est aussi savoir où
appliquer le discours, sur qui peser et
cetera et cetera. Et le magnifique
résultat, c'est celui dont je te parle.
C'est-à-dire que George Bush ne parle
pas un mot sur l'Arabie Saoudite après
le 11 septembre. Donc tu vois pourquoi
le complexe militaire ou intellectuel
c'est pas les industriels seulement,
c'est tout un certain nombre de
collaborateurs. Moi j'ai fait une note
[raclement de gorge] quand j'ai sorti
mon bouquin sur le le lobby saoudien en
France. Non, c'était sur docteur Saoud
et Mr Dihan. C'estàd j'ai fait une étude
sur la diplomatie religieuse de l'Arabie
Saoudite
dont il est difficile de contester qu'il
a une diplomatie religieuse. Bon, j'ai
eu une note incendiaire du qu d'ors
disant que j'étais saoudophobe.
Bon, moi je leur répondu qu'il me
paraissait que c'était peut-être
saoudophile qui était un problème mais
enfin visiblement c'était pas le cas. Et
donc tu as à l'intérieur du système des
gens qui sont prêts à écrire des textes
complètement inominieux sur le sujet.
C'est-à-dire si tu critiques l'Arabie
Saoudite, c'est que c'est saoudophobe.
Le fait que ça t'en touché une de se
faire bouger l'autre l'Arabie Saoudite,
ça ils s'en foutent, ils jouent leur
rôle. Alors, j'ai été assez perfide
puisque j'ai passé la note au canard
enchaîné et le canard enchaîné, on a
fait évidemment une de ces brèves qui
font leur réputation, mais ayant sachant
ce que fait comme effet le fait qu'on te
mentionne dans le canard enchaîné le
mardi soir, ça met toute une
administration en branle. C'est-à-dire
que là, je savais que [rires] ça devait
être une pagaille terrible si tu veux
dans le qu d'ors moi. Donc tu vois
comment finalement un système de résiste
à des réalités effectives comme
celle-là.
Et donc tu vas avoir des gens qui sont
des sociétés de relation publique, tu
vas avoir des intellectuels médiatiques,
tu vas avoir des humanitaires, tu voisas
des tas de gens qui à partir de la
disparition de l'URSS vont dire "Telle
crise est importante." Et pourquoi elle
est importante ? Parce que il y a un
massacre, on ne peut pas ne pas et
cetera et cetera. Alors, comment se fait
le mécanisme ? Le mécanisme, il se fait
justement par l'intermédiaire de cet
autre aspect de la guerre, c'est-à-dire
l'apparition des plateaux télé et des
chaînes d'info en continu. Les chaînes
d'info en continu, c'est donc de
l'information où tous les jours il doit
y avoir quelque chose de nouveau.
Donc à chaque fois que je suis invité
sur un plateau télé, on me pose la
question qu'est-ce que va faire Poutine
? C'est évident que tu vas faire
Poutine. Si tu dis "Je n'en sais rien",
tu joues pas le jeu parce que tu dis
mais oui vous mais vous êtes un expert.
Tu dis non mais moi pas plus que les
autres personnes qui sont sur ce plateau
n'ont rencontré Poutine. Donc pourquoi
voulez-vous qu'on sache ? Alors que
l'ensemble de cette communauté s'est
trompé en pensant que Poutine n'oserait
jamais faire cette bêtise d'envahir
l'Ukraine. Donc tu vois quand je dis le
c'est un système qui mélange une
alchimie des plateaux télé avec un
certain nombre de spécialistes entre
guillemets experts et cetera qui vont
venir pour expliquer la la chose. Si on
transpose l'analyse sur un sujet qu'on a
tous vécu qui est le Covid. Le Covid
c'est prodigieux, maladie que personne
ne connaît, mais tout à coup les
plateaux télés sont peuplés de
spécialistes du Covid. Alors ça va être
le mec qui est neurologue, le mec qui
est spécialiste des allergies, le mec
qui est pneumologue, enfin j'en sais
rien. Mais tu vas avoir plein de
spécialistes du Covid d'une maladie que
personne ne connaît. Mais parce que
l'attirance médiatique, c'est-à-dire la
capacité à apparaître dans un média tout
à coup change les termes du débat. C'est
l'apparition dans le média qui fait
l'expert, c'est pas la connaissance du
sujet. Donc tu vois bien qu'avec le avec
le cas du Covid là, ce sujet où on a
beaucoup moins de composantes, tu vois
bien que on a dû draîner, je sais pas 30
ou 40 ou 50 spécialistes du Covid encore
une fois d'une maladie que personne ne
connaissait. Donc tu vois comment le le
mécanisme médiatique si tu veux change
le processus décisionnel et en tout cas
s'adresse à l'opinion
pour donner le sentiment que on maîtrise
le sujet pour montrer qu'on interpelle
le politique sur ce qu'il doit faire pas
faire et cetera. J'ouvre une parenthèse.
[raclement de gorge] Tu parles du Covid,
imagine-toi, c'est une maladie qu'on
connaît pas. Rappelle-toi les départs,
les départs de l'information qui a eu en
France après tout le monde. Le coûpt des
masques, on met les masques, on met pas
les masques, est-ce qu'on sort ? Est-ce
qu'on sort pas ? Est-ce que c'est
aéroporté, pas aéroporté ? Et ainsi de
suite.
Il fallait bien rassurer la population.
Il fallait bien dire "Vous inquiétez
pas, tout se passe bien parce que tu
connais la la psychologie des foules de
Gustave Lebont,
une foule qui est en panique à l'âge
mental d'un gamin de 5 ans."
Donc bon papa de l'État avec sa ministre
de la santé a rassuré
ça. C'est un scandale. C'est un scandale
sanitaire pour plus tard. On gérera ça
dans les 10 prochaines années. Qu'est-ce
que ça aurait changé ?
Si quoi ?
S'il avait inquiété, c'està-dire en
disant ne sortez plus de chez vous.
Bah
c'était pire. Bah non, mais justement
c'est pour ça que le rôle des experts si
tu veux c'était de faire comprendre
qu'après tout on maîtrise le sujet, on
le comprend, on l'analyse, on maîtrise
le sujet. Donc
on a progressé par petit pas si tu veux,
mais c'est ce qui est intéressant encore
une fois, c'est cette articulation entre
des chaînes d'info qui tous les matins
doivent dire quelque chose de nouveau
avec l'appel à une coorte d'experts
entre guillemets qui vont venir te dire
des demi-vérités, des demi faussetés,
mais en tout cas donner le sentiment que
étant en blouse blanche, ils vont
trouver une solution. Bon, le paroxisme
étant évidemment Raoul disant que après
tout avec la l'hydrochloroquine, on on
aurait pu régler tout ça. Donc tu vois
que c'est le c'est les médias qui
rendent fous.
Les médias rendent fous et le et à
[raclement de gorge] partir de ce
moment-là, bah
les médias rendent fous mais les spin
doctors qui s'expriment dans les médias
alors qu'ils ont un agenda, comment on
fait pour les reconnaître ? Est-ce que
c'est bien, c'est pas bien ? Est-ce que
ça participe au débat démocratique ?
c'est simplement réduire l'opinion
publique à un courant qu'on doit
diriger vers la gauche ou vers la droite
selon le vouloir ou les capacités de
notre de notre gouvernement à agir. Non,
moi je suis moins moins radical que toi
parce que encore une fois chacun ne peut
délivrer qu'une petite vérité en tout
cas dans son domaine de spécialité et
donc il en il pense contribuer à une
espèce d'œuvre de salubrité publique en
venant expliquer ce que lui pense de la
propagation de la maladie, de sa
dangérosité et cetera et cetera. Bon, en
même temps, on met en branle tous des
instituts officiels, l'institut de les
instituts sanitaires et autres qui
eux-mêmes continuent leur recherche.
Mais tu es médecin, tu es dans un
service hospitalier, on te propose de
venir ce que tu penses toi de l'opé de
la gravité de cette maladie encore une
fois qui présente des formes mal
connues. Qu'est-ce que tu fais ? Tu n'y
vas pas en disant je je ne sais rien, je
n'en sais rien. Tu vois le le la
responsabilité est pas facile à
déterminer. Si les médecins avaient
refusé de parler, ça dit "Mais ces
types, ils s'en foutent. Or, ils sont
venus, ils ont parlé et on va leur
reprocher d'avoir parlé sans savoir de
quoi il parlait." Alors, revenons à la
guerre.
Ouais.
Un intellectuel médiatique qui vient
s'exprimer.
Oui.
Il s'exprime pour la la gloire, la fame,
pour l'argent. Pourquoi ?
Non, je crois qu'il s'exprime. Bon, si
tu prends des cas connus, évidemment,
pour ne citer que BHL, c'est pas une
question d'argent. C'est un type qui a
de l'argent, il est d'une grande famille
industrielle et cetera. Bon, mais euh
lui ce qu'il recherche évidemment c'est
la notoriété, la reconnaissance
internationale, enfin la reconnaissance
évidemment sur le le territoire français
et cetera.
Tu penses ça, tu n'es pas dans la tête
de BHL.
Ah non, je suis pas dans la tête de BHL.
Non non, mais si tu veux, c'est pas un
type qui demande de l'argent, c'est pas
il se fait pas payer pour ça. Bon, mais
en même temps, ça te renvoie un modèle
social qui est typiquement français qui
est justement l'intellectuel.
C'est quand même une caractéristique
française. Nous, nous avons une
tradition d'intellectuel universaliste,
c'est-à-dire depuis l'époque des
Lumière, Rousseau, Voltaire, Mig et
cetera, on montre que on a révolutionné
la connaissance et donc ce modèle a été
créé évidemment pour a été a donné
naissance si tu veux à une école de
pensée qui fait que l'intellectuel va
être un espèce de référent pour la
société auquel il faut s'adresser quand
on comprend pas. Bon, en plus, il y a
l'épisode Zola, c'est-à-dire que Zola va
mettre tout son poids euh qui était déjà
énorme pour défendre un individu Drefus
qui était injustement condamné mais face
à une institution gigantesque qui
s'appelait armée. Et donc le combat de
Zola, c'est aussi la dignité de cette
catégorie des intellectuels.
C'est-à-dire que le type va essayer de
de faire prévaloir la vérité par rapport
à des postures officielles. Et on est
encore une fois dans des dans des phases
où on est en préparation de guerre avec
l'Allemagne, c'est-à-dire critiquer
l'armée, c'était considéré comme une
espèce de trahison. Donc on a jamais su
d'ailleurs de quoi Zola était mort. On
sait que son poil tirait mal et qu'il
s'était qui s'est asfixé mais on a
jamais réussi à savoir s'il y avait une
une intention maligne ou pas. Bon, donc
cette tradition-là fait que intellectuel
universaliste, intellectuel défenseur du
pauvre et de l'orphelin, euh ça va
donner naissance à euh une troisème
catégorie qui était historiquement
importante qui va être la catégorie
Sartre, c'est-à-dire Sartre va être
considéré comme le grand intellectuel
des années 50 60 70 en France.
Or, il y a pas un individu qui s'est
plus systématiquement trompé sur les
questions internationales que lui. Il a
été stalinien, il a été maoïste, il a
défendu le Cambodge. Bon, il s il s'est
battu pour l'indépendance de l'Algérie.
Donc ça, au moins sur ce côté-là, il a
eu raison. Mais le fait qu'il a eu ce
cursus ou en pensant que c'était la
révolution qui devait résoudre les
contradictions de la démocratie, c'était
une époque où on considérait que le
méchant c'était Aaron et le gentil
c'était Sartre.
On en est un peu revenu mais il reste
que ce modèle de l'intellectuel
dans lequel l'idéologie l'emporte sur la
réalité, c'est ça qui est la démarche
importante, fait que l'intellectuel se
met dans une position, il il dit mais au
aux auditeurs "Mais j'en sais plus que
vous, je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
c'est comme ça, tu vois ? que tu as à la
fois une posture qui est une posture de
prestige. Je suis un intellectuel, je
vais vous expliquer parce que je vais
vous utiliser tel argumentaire, tel
qu'on référence idéologique et cetera et
puis ensuite tu ben tu obtiens un statut
si tu veux qui va être qu'est-ce que BHL
pense d'eux ? Bon, c'est pas le seul
hein, c'est pas le seul. Il faut pas que
l'individu, la figure de pro du système
cache le système. Il y en a d'autres qui
sont des référents universels. Par
exemple, il y en a un autre que j'adore,
c'est Alexandre Adler. Alexandre Adler
est un type qui justement écrit surtout.
Il est malade donc on il faut en trouver
un autre parce qu'on parle pas des gens
malades.
Bah tu sais quand il écrivait, il était
en bonne santé. Quand il expliquait il y
a encore 3 semaines que Poutine allait
être victime d'un complot
et que la guerre serait finie au mois de
juin. Donc ça va, on peut le dire
puisque ça on arrive à la mi-juin déjà.
Alors la technique de Hler, elle vaut la
peine d'être référencée parce que tu
peux la filer à quelquun notes. Tu cites
les services de renseignement. Si je te
dis d'après mes sources de
renseignement, les services pakistanais
sont en charge de l'extermination de je
sais pas quoi, desigours.
Tu vas jamais avoir un mec dans une
salle qui va lever la main en disant
"Excusez-moi, je suis le porte-parole
des services pakistanais. Vous racontez
n'importe quoi." Le référence que tu
fais en citant des services de
renseignement, c'est que tu es sûr que
jamais personne te contredira. Bon, donc
là, tu peux dire Poutine va être l'objet
d'un complot qui va l'assassiner.
J'ai des sources dans les services de
renseignement qui me disent que
c'est c'est c'est vachement prestigieux.
Ça te donne l'impression que tu connais.
Tu vois quand tu te lances dans des
supputations comme celle-là et que tu te
dis "Mais ça c'est des mecs qui tiennent
des positions de pouvoir à France
Culture, dans les médias et cetera et
cetera, tu te dis mais pourquoi le
système ne les épure pas à un certain
moment ?" C'est-à-dire épisode vécu.
L'autre fois, j'étais dans un dans un
débat
à côté d'un chef d'étatmajor de l'armée
de l'air, enfin un ancien chef
d'étatmajor de l'armée de l'air
français. On se met à discuter, on se
connaissait depuis longtemps. Il me
raconte son entretien avec BHL sortant
de l'Élysée pour aller faire la guerre
en Libye.
Et BHL vient lui expliquer à lui comment
il fallait faire la guerre au lib. Or,
lui avait fait la guerre au liben
puisqu'il avait combattu pendant pour la
histoire de la bande d'Ozu, donc
quelques années plus tôt. Il me dit "Ce
type est fou. Ce type est fou." Bref, on
va dans le débat, on discute et cetera.
On sort et qui on voit invité en vedette
américaine BHL.
Alors, je me tourne vers la file de la
télé, je dis "Mais attendez, pourquoi
vous l'invitez seul ? Vous avez ici
quelqu'un qui l'a pratiqué, vous pouvez
le garder, vous aurez un débat. Ah, je
vais en parler à la direction de la
chaîne." Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Tu vois comment le système se met en
place ? [raclement de gorge]
Le problème c'est effectivement de le
dépioter, de le faire que tu te que tu
expliques ces excès si tu veux que que
ça génère et encore une fois c'est pris
d'opposition parce qu' le destinataire
final de ce complexe militarau
intellectuel c'est de peser sur le
politique. C'est ça le la chose. Donc
tant que le politique lui-même n'a pas
d'expérience internationale, qu'il a pas
fait le service militaire, qu'il se dit
il y a les élections municipales dans 3
mois et cetera et cetera, les éléments
de son sa décision n'ont plus rien à
voir avec la crise. les éléments de sa
décision, c'est je montre que je
m'occupe de ça, je montre que je suis
décisionnel.
J'ouvre une parenthèse, ces
intellectuels médiatiques
qui sont amenés à conseiller nos
politiciens,
est-ce que les services, ils font une
enquête de proximité pour savoir qui les
payent, où est-ce qu'ils vont en
vacances, qu'est-ce qui se balade, quels
sont leurs potes, est-ce qu'ils sont
influencés par une puissance étrangère
ou peut-être par une autre puissance ?
Est-ce qu'ils ont un agenda en
particulier ?
Non non non, là tu es dans une posture
gu froide. Non non là tu tu donnes des
explications qui qui étit vrai à
l'époque de la guerre froide.
Est-ce qu'il faut pas revenir à ça ?
Pardon ?
Non parce qu'encore une fois si tu veux
le prestige médiatique est une
rémunération en soi. Enf rémunération un
acquis en soi.
L'influence
de nos politiques d'état c'est quand
même notre
pouvoir régalien qui est attaqué. d'une
façon euh fourbe par des canau une soft
power guerre une
Oui, c'est un soft power si tu veux mais
il est pas instrumentalisé à mon avis il
y a pas nécessité d'instrumentaliser si
ce n'est le
il y a pas il y a pas un lobby saoudien
il y a pas un lobby américain il y a pas
un lobby russe il y a pas un lobby Qatar
il y a pas un lobby is français
c'est c'estes deux questions différentes
que tu poses si ces types sont animés
par des intérêts financiers non c'est
pas le cas
[raclement de gorge] simplement encore
une fois, on vit dans une société du
spectacle he c'est pas moi, c'est de
bord qui a inventé ça. Ça veut dire que
l'apparition sur des chaînes de télé,
l'apparition dans des chaînes d'info en
continu donne le sentiment que tu es un
des grands penseurs et un des grands
acteurs de la vie politique. Si le
politique lui-même considère que
l'interpellation est suffisamment
efficace pour queil faille que tu
prennes une décision, les éléments de sa
décision, c'est pas l'intérêt de la
crise elle-même. L'intérêt, c'est les
éléments de sa décision, c'est qu'est-ce
que j'en tire électoralement. Bon et
encore une fois on a eu le cas si tu
veux de gens qui regarde le cas de la
Libye le cas de la Libye est fascinant.
On va avoir un individu qui est allé en
Libye qui me qui revient en disant "J'ai
rencontré les insurgés, il y a le
nouveau Massou." Tu vois la référence ?
Il y a le nouveau Massou, il faut aller
les aider et il va réussir à convaincre
un président de la République qu'il faut
absolument solliciter un mandat de l'ONU
pour aller empêcher les Kaddafi de
profiter de sa supériorité aérienne
puisque tu te souviens qu'il y avait des
manifestations dans toute la partie
orientale de la Libye et que par contre
Kaddafi tenait sa capitale et
l'essentiel de son armée et donc il
avait une supériorité que les autres
n'avaient pas, c'était effectivement son
armée de l'air.
Donc, on fait adopter un mandat à l'ONU
qu'on appelle un mandat d'interdiction
de survol, c'est-à-dire que les forces
aériennes françaises et anglaises devait
empêcher les forces libiennes de
décoller. Chose qui effectivement s'est
passé, mais il y a un moment où sur le
terrain commence à apparaître l'idée
qu'il y a une colonne de char qui se
dirige vers Tripoli. Bah ouais, mais
alors est-ce qu'on est dans le mandat ou
pas ? Bon, très rapidement, le mandat
d'interdiction de surpul va devenir un
mandat d' non non explicite de
destruction d'une colonne de char. Et à
partir de ce moment-là, si tu veux, on
devient acteur de la guerre. Bon et
encore une fois, sans que ça soit
explicité comme tel, mais le ressort
premier, tu te souviens, c'est la
position de BHL qui va réussir à
convaincre un homme d'état que
effectivement il y a beaucoup de choses
à tirer de cette action puisque personne
adorer Kaddafi. Kaddafi était l'exemple
même si tu veux du de l'individu qui
était un peu jetbé, qui était à la fois
un grand leader et en même temps une
espèce de délire. Enfin, c'était
étonnant. La Libye des Liby était une
Libye où les gens vivaient bien. Ils
répartissaient la la mane pétrolière.
Euh simplement, il y avait la censure
absolue. Bon et puis il y avait
évidemment police politique, tout ce que
tu as. Mais l'idée de détruire un régime
comme celui-là, vu de Saint-Germain des
Prè, c'est une mission de service
public. Donc le fait que notre individu
aille voir le président en disant "J'en
viens, il y a une insurrection, il faut
les protéger et cetera." nos avions, bah
ils sont commencés à bombarder
la pseudo ou la soi-disant colonne de
chat. Et à travers la mo demande la
colonne de chat, il y a tout le reste
qui va s'enchaîner, c'est-à-dire le fait
que effectivement Kaddafi est paralysé,
il a plus le moyen d'utiliser son armée
qui commence à bouger et cetera et
finalement il est intercepté par les par
les insurgés et il est lyché. Bon donc
tu te dis on voit bien comment quelque
chose dont on pouvait justifier au
départ que c'est à partir d'une bonne
intention débarrasser la terre d'une
dictature. Enfin si c'était devenu une
mission de service public, il y aurait
beaucoup de boulot quoi. Et donc on
avait choisi cette cible. Je laisse de
tomber le l'idée que c'est SarkoZi a pu
toucher du pognon de Kaddafi ou pas,
j'en sais rien. Je m'en fous. Ce qui
m'intéresse c'est comment on convaint
une société et sa son armée de vouloir
intervenir dans un conflit en disant on
ne peut pas ne pas. Voilà. Donc c'est ça
qui m'a intéressé.
Tous ces gars qui sont répandus
[raclement de gorge] sur les plateaux
télé, est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui les
tient
comptable de ce qu'ils ont raconté ?
Ah non. Ah ben non. Ah ben non, surtout
pas. Si tu veux
le Je te prends l'exemple de Sart, mais
je pourrais te le prendre pareil pour
BHL.
Ce sont des intellectuels téfales,
c'est-à-dire sont des gens sur lesquels
aucune critique n'accroche. Aucune. Par
exemple,
BHL est interviewé sur une chaîne de
télé 2 ans après la le renversement de
Kaddafi. On est dans la deuxème période
de la guerre civile libienne. C'est la
deuxième guerre de bataille de Tripoli.
Et [raclement de gorge] donc le le
journaliste pose la question à BHL et
BHL dit cette phrase extraordinaire. Il
dit "Tant mieux si j'y suis pour quelque
chose." Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est-à-dire que on a effectivement,
mais je te pourrais t'en citer d'autres
exemples, de gens qui de toute façon ne
considèrent qu'ils avaient tort raison à
l'époque et qu'ils ont encore raison
aujourd'hui, même si c'est exactement
l'effet néfaste. Regarde le regarde le
l'impact des guerres qu'on a déclenché
après le 11 septembre.
L'Irak, Afghanistan, 20 ans de guerre en
Afghanistan pour voir revenir les
talibans. Destruction de l'Irak,
destruction hein, parce que la campagne
aérienne sur l'Irak déclenchée par
George Bouche, c'est on rase tout et
puis ensuite il demande la paix. pas et
donc quand les troupes débarquent en
Irak et que les mecs n'ont plus ni
l'électricité ni la sécurité et cetera
et cetera qui mettent une espèce de
branleur qui s'appelle Bremer gouverneur
général de l'Irak un américain qui avait
probablement jamais mis les pieds hors
des États-Unis ce type va démonter tous
les services de sécurité tous les
services de police et cetera et donc on
va rentrer dans cette période de guerre
civile irakienne. Bon et le discours des
Américains c'était oui mais vous avez de
la chance maintenant vous avez la
démocratie.
Alors, tu vois l'adéquation entre
l'outil militaire et l'objectif
politique. Si tu détruis un pays que les
mecs se sentent plus mal que à l'époque
de la dictature, on peut pas dire que tu
es rempli ton objectif politique. Donc
après l'effet induit, ça va être la
Syrie et cetera. Et donc maintenant, on
a laissé au Moyen-Orient une pagaille
comme c'était inimaginable.
Ce qui est intéressant dans le encore
une fois dans ce complexe militaroint
intellectuel, reprenons le cas de
l'Irak.
Donc tu vois que alors que ça n'avait
aucun rapport que les irakiens n'avaient
aucun rapport avec l'attentat du 11
septembre, donc George Bouche va décider
l'invasion de l'Irak. Il y a deux forces
politiques qui poussent George Bouche à
cette décision. [raclement de gorge]
La première c'est les néoconservateurs.
Les néoconservateurs sont ces gens qui à
part le 91 se sont sentis tout à coup
pouser des ailes puisqu'ils disent
"Voyez, on est la seule superpuissance.
Si nous avons gagné, c'est que nous
sommes le camp du bien et donc il faut
qu'on répende le bien sur la planète."
C'est une tradition américaine qui est
assez ancienne. He n'oublie pas que les
pères fondateurs arrivent aux
États-Unis.
Ils édiquent une théorie qui s'appelle
la théorie de la destinée manifeste,
c'est-à-dire manifestement Dieu nous a
mandaté pour faire de ce pays le paradis
sur terre. Bon, ensuite, ils vont
étendre le paradis en Amérique latine
avec différentes interventions. Enfin,
tu vois la conception que ça traduisait
derrière. Et donc tu ces
néoconservateurs se disent en 91, ben
voyez finalement le l'empire du mal a
disparu. Donc c'est que nous avons
raison. Donc nous sommes le camp du
bien. Donc cela entoure George Bouche.
Ensuite tu vas avoir les néovangéliques.
Les néovangéliques, c'est la phase
protestante du radicalisme religieux.
C'est-à-dire c'est des mecs qui euh en
bref les pères fondateurs arrivent aux
États-Unis. Ce sont des protestants qui
ont été persécutés par beaucoup de
notamment par des catholiques, par des
d'autres protestants et donc vont se
trouver tranquilles aux États-Unis.
Le phénomène qui se passe et qui
commence à les inquiéter beaucoup, c'est
quand à la fin du 19e siècle commence à
arriver des migrants espagnols, italien,
irlandais, c'est-à-dire des catholiques.
À ce moment-là, ils se disent "Mais
attendez, on a quitté le on a été chassé
d'Europe par eux, on va pas les
accueillir." Donc il y a un mouvement de
radicalisme dans le protestantisme
américain qui s'appelle les réveils
d'Azousa. C'est une ville dans
lesquelles ils ont tout à coup formalisé
le fait qu'il fallait résister à cette
arrivée des des catholiques. et puis
ensuite ça va se formaliser sous la
forme comment dire qui va participer à
des décisions de de politique étrangère
quand il va se passer la guerre de
l'Irak ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ces gens-là ont une posture totalement
théologique. Ils disent pas il faut
détruire Saddam Hussein parce que c'est
un méchant il torture et cetera. Ils
disent le Messie nous a l'Ancien
Testament garantit que le retour du
Messie se fera quand sera constitué le
grand Israël. Donc une des conditions
c'est la disparition de Saddam Hussein.
Donc ils vont approuiller cette guerre
pour des raisons encore une fois
totalement théologiques. Et donc tu te
dis mais attends, on les a pas vu
arriver ou quoi ? Si on les a vu arriver
simplement on faisait comme si puisque
c'était le camp du bien et que l'autre
c'était le camp du mal, il y avait pas à
chercher les excuses. Donc tu vois
comment des strates très différentes et
qui encore une fois n'ont rien à voir
avec des questions stratégiques vont
décider d'intervention militaire. Et
j'ai calculé que depuis 91, porté par
cette espèce d'Ubris, cette ivresse
guerrière qui nous a occupé après la
disparition de l'URSS, on a fait une
trentaine d'interventions militaires.
Une trentaine. On a fait quatre guerres
en Irak en Moyen-Orient. On a fait un
certain nombre d'interventions en
Afrique. Enfin bref. Donc quand tu te
mets de l'autre côté, c'est tu te mets
du côté de Poutine
ou Sadam
ou Saddam. Bon Saddam, il avait disparu
emporté à nos à notre affection comme tu
le sais. Mais quand tu tu te dis
aujourd'hui Poutine, il dit "Mais
attends, ces mecs, ils ont pas cessé
d'intervenir sur la planète entière. Ils
ont étendu l'autemp des des comment dire
des promesses orales qui avaient été
faites à à Yelsin.
Euh [raclement de gorge] et finalement
même quand il y a eu le cas de la
Serbie, tu te souviens l'affaire de
l'ugoslavie,
la Serbie donc qui était à l'origine de
la guerre civile pendant laquelle on
était intervenu, on avait réussi à
établir des conditions de la paix enfin
avec l'aide des Américains et cetera.
Mais il leur reste un morceau qui
s'appelle le Kosovo. Le Kosovo, c'était
une région qui était maintenant peublée
peuplée d'albanophone. Mais les Serbes
disent "Ah non, ça c'est pas possible.
C'est la terre où est née la Serbie." Tu
vois, tu reconnais un certain nombre de
discours utilisés un peu partout
aujourd'hui. Vous pouvez pas toucher à
cette terre parce que historiquement
c'est la nôtre. Voilà. Donc nous
occidentaux, on va dire "Non, non, c'est
pas possible qu'on laisse les Serbes
massacrer des Cosovars, massacrer des
albanophones. Donc on va bombarder la
Serbie. 50 jours de bombardement.
Les Russes qui se sentent solidaires des
Serbes parce qu'encore une fois c'est la
même école religieuse et les orthodoxes
machin et cetera, ils l'ont en travers
de la gorge. Il disent mais enfin vous
auriez pu nous associer parce qu'on
aurait peut-être pu convaincre. Bon mais
tu vois qu'on est dans un cas où on va
bombarder pour pouvoir libérer un
territoire alors qu'aujourd'hui on
voudrait interdire à Poutine de
bombarder pour libérer un territoire. Tu
vois le l'inversion du système. Donc le
les Russes ont eu ce sentiment que
l'extension de l'OTAN qui est arrivé à
leur frontière, l'idée qu'on puisse
avoir des missiles balistiques à la à
leur à la juste à la limite de la
frontière de la Russie, le fait qu'il
reste 20 25 millions de Russes hors de
Russie,
on a un problème sur le sur le ventre
qui est très lourd. Et donc encore une
fois, si à chaque fois tu vois arriver
des gens qui disent "Non non, il faut
faire c, il faut faire ça, il faut faire
c, faut faire ça," ils ne veulent pas se
rendre compte que derrière il y a une
espèce de de bombe à retardement. Tu
vois, si on fait semblant que les
Russes, la revendication des Russes ne
peut pas être prise en considération
parce qu'ils ont envahi, ce qui est
vrai. En même temps, on se dit "Ouais,
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe demain s'il
décide de faire la même chose au
Kazakhstan ? C'est pas l'OTAN qui va
aller défendre le Kazakhstan."
Donc au lieu de se mettre dans une
posture de diplomatie et de négociation
comme le fait Macron, tu as encore sur
les plateaux télé des tas de gens qui
disent "Non non, [raclement de gorge] il
faut faire plus, il faut faire moins.
Nous les Français, on n'est pas assz
ici, on est passé ça." Voilà donc c'est
ça que le complexe militarau
intellectuel encore une fois avec l'idée
de surtout pas y aller faire la guerre
he faut pas confondre quand même.
C'est c'est c'est du militaire de
plateau télé.
C'est c'est du bellicisme de plateau
télé. C'est pas du militaire. Les
militaires c'est une génération qui
apparaît maintenant. Les militaires sont
pas bélicistes pour un sous d'habitude.
Bah non, ils sont pas bélicistes. Ils
savent ce que c'est que la guerre à la
différence de BHL si tu veux. Ben non,
le [raclement de gorge]
génération de Malerot ou de Régis de
Bré, ils vont pas faire la guerre. Ils
disent il faut envoyer des militaires.
Et donc les militaires disent "Oui,
d'accord, nous on veut bien mais nous on
est fait pour faire la guerre. On n'est
pas fait pour faire de l'interposition.
On n'est pas fait [raclement de gorge]
pour faire de l'humanitaire, on n'est
pas fait pour ça." Ils refusent pas, ils
sont obéissants mais enfin ils se
trouvent dans des difficultés. Je te dis
l'exemple du de la Somalie est très très
significatif.
Par exemple, Somalie,
quand on commence à comprendre que il y
a des gens qui pillent les convois
humanitaires,
donc c'est un côté scandaleux. On pille
les convois humanitaires alors que c'est
destiné à nourrir des populations
affamées et cetera.
[raclement de gorge] J'en parle avec
Broman.
R
R R Ban qui me dit j'ai appelé mes
équipes sur place, ils me disent que les
types qui attaquent les convois ne sont
pas des voleurs. Ils ne vendent pas, ils
ne revendent pas. Ils apportent la
nourriture à leur clan parce qu'ils
estiment qu'ils sont mal servis. Bon,
donc il essaye les types lui disent si
on augmente le flux, on peut calmer une
partie de la de la violence locale. Et
donc il va essayer d'aller
[raclement de gorge] à Bruxelles à New
York pour plaider le l'augmentation. Et
pendant qu'il est là-bas, Kouchner,
ancien humanitaire devenu ministre,
décide l'intervention militaire. Tu vois
le changement de posture ?
[raclement de gorge] On a donc des
mutations comme ça de gens qui
progressivement ont participé à ce
complexe militaire ou intellectuel pour
aboutir à l'usage de la force armée, ce
qui n'a réglé strictement aucune crise.
Aucune.
Si ce n'est la crise du Cos.
Revenons, revenons à la à la population,
nous
nos amis, les gens qui travaillent dans
nos quartiers,
nos agriculteurs, les gens normaux.
Euh quel est l'intérêt de les convaincre
à aller en guerre ? En général, les
populations n'ont aucun intérêt à aller
en guerre. On a vraiment l'impression
qu'on leur vend
une route bien balisé pour aller faire
la guerre.
Ben si tu veux, l'histoire de la France,
c'est l'histoire d'une d'un empire
colonial quand même.
Ils vont se faire calmer à l'arrivée de
l'hiver quand même.
Pardon ? Ils vont se
ils vont ils vont se faire calmer à
l'arrivée de l'hiver. Plus de gaz, plus
de matière première, la facture
énergétique.
Alors ça c'est autre chose si tu veux.
Ça c'est les conséquences de la crise
ukrainienne. Mais tu ta première
question c'était comment est-ce qu'on a
en convainc l'opinion ? Bon première
remarque, on
convaincre je dirais influencer
l'opinion.
Oui, influencer si tu veux. Première
remarque, on est dans des armées de
métiers.
Algérie avait définitivement bloqué
l'idée d'envoyer des membres du
contingent si tu veux sur des théâtres
extérieurs. On a pu encore le faire en
Yogoslavie mais dans l'ensemble après ça
c'est pas de pas de d'envoi du
contingent de de troufions si tu veux
sur des lieux de crise. Bon et donc
quand Chirak décide la
professionnalisation à ce moment-là on n
qu'une armée sur lesquelles il y a aucun
doute c'est-à-dire c'est le bras armé de
l'État. Bon, le [raclement de gorge]
on se trouve alors à ce moment-là avec
un outil qui est beaucoup plus facile à
utiliser. La question c'est de
convaincre le politique qu'il faut
utiliser ce moyen-là. Bon et donc à la
limite l'opinion publique importe peu.
En quoi elle est concerné ? Parce que
c'est plus ces enfants qui vont se
battre. Au contraire, ça donne le
sentiment que la France est une
puissance, que la France, on va
l'interroger pour essayer de résoudre la
crise en Yougoslavie, qu'on va essayer
de résoudre la crise à tel endroit et
cetera. Regarde le regarde le processus
Chirak Sarkozy euh Hollande
quand George Bouche décide d'envahir
l'Irak
euh encore une fois qui n'avait aucune
responsabilité dans les attentats du 11
septembre. Chirak dit non. Il dit non
non c'est une connerie on nira pas et on
mettra notre véau. Ce qui était vraiment
le crime de l' Majesté suprême. Bon il
se trouve qu'il était avec les Russes en
plus à dire qu'il mettrait leur véau
mais pour les Américains, c'était un
choc.
Ma fille était aux États-Unis à ce
moment-là. Moi, j'y suis allé aussi. Le
French bashing aux États-Unis, ça déliré
absolument.
Ils ont changé le nom des frites. Rien
que pour
Oui. Oui. Ils ont changé le nom des
frites. Les French fries, c'est devenu
je sais pas quoi. Les Liberty les
Liberty Fri.
Mais c'est surtout cette espèce d'idée
que comment pouvait-on contester la
décision de la plus grande démocratie du
monde ?
Et donc
le bras armé de Dieu.
Le bras armé de Dieu. Oui, surtout
effectivement lui alors George Bouche
c'était l'exemple même du Ben Laden
local parce que tu sais dans ces
radicalismes religieux qui soient
d'ailleurs musulman, néoconservateur,
néoangélique, juif, hindouiste ou
bouddhiste, tu as un phénomène c'est ce
qu'on appelle la renaissance. Dès que tu
adhères à cette idéologie, tu reviens à
Reborn. Rappelle-toi que Ben Laden,
c'était un Reborn Muslim. Il avait
redécouvert la religion et par contre
Georgio Bush était devenu un rebond
Christian
après après son troulit la gueule. Il
était ivr tout à coup il découvre la
religion mais il y avait des séances
autour de lui à la maison blanche où il
s'arrêtait pour prier tous ensemble. Bon
donc tu as des deux côtés si tu veux
cette espèce de posture des radicaux qui
se disent "Mais de toute façon nous
sommes mandatés par Dieu donc tout le
les autres ne peuvent être que des
représentants du diable."
Donc tu as cette [raclement de gorge]
espèce de pression qui s'est fait de
différentes modalités qui va aboutir à
cette catastrophe qui est l'invasion de
l'Irak avec toute la guerre civile qui
va s'en suivre et cetera et cetera. Mais
encore une fois, tu n'as jamais eu une
autocritique même quand les comment dire
on s'est rendu compte que effectivement
c'était une bêtise. Personne n'a rendu
hommage à Chirak aux États-Unis. Il en
était pas question. Et au contraire,
Chirak est trahi par les siens.
C'est-à-dire que les ces deux
successeurs à l'Élysée vont s'engager
dans la guerre dans la roue des
Américain comme si le
c'était écrit c'était cousu fil blanc
Sarkozi l'américain.
Oui mais enfin tu pouvais te dire
qu'après tout il s'était rendu compte
que ça s'enlisait que les Américains
merdaient et cetera et cetera. Bon, il y
va, il faudra en parler avec lui, il
faudrait l'interviewer. Mais l'autre
après Hollande, président du conseil
général de la Corè qui y va aussi, tu te
dis mais qu'est-ce [raclement de gorge]
qui a pu les motiver pour aller se
mettre dans ce dans ce bourbier ? Donc,
tu vois que il y a un processus
décisionnel qui ne concerne absolument
pas l'opinion. Ça se fait hors de
l'opinion. Ça se fait avec des gens qui
expliquent comment on ne peut pas ne pas
vous rendez compte, regardez ce qui se
passe. Il faut aller sauver des vies, il
faut aller sauver des femmes, faut aller
sauver des enfants, tout ce que tu veux.
Mais la pagaille, c'est nous qui l'avons
installé là-bas.
Bon, alors au bout du compte, tu te dis
euh
sur l'Ukraine, on a pas installé de
pagaille là.
Sur la l'Ukraine, pardon.
Ou on n pas installé de pagaille ?
Non, on n' pas installé de pagaille.
Alors, l'Ukraine, si tu veux, c'est un
processus qu'il faut prendre comme la
décomposition d'un empire.
Descomposition d'un empire, c'est
l'URSS, hein. Tu tu connais le truc.
Cette décomposition va se caractériser
par deux choses. Bon, d'abord c'est une
un écroulement par l'intérieur. C'est
pas un empire qui est détruit par une
invasion extérieure, c'est un empire qui
s'écroule sur lui-même. Il va se
traduire par deux choses qui sont
extrêmement pénibles, c'est que des
frontières administratives deviennent
des frontières politiques. [grognement]
Or, ces frontières administratives a été
faite dans un à l'époque d'un jeune
homme qui s'appelait Joseph Stalin qui
était commissaire aux nationalité dont
le seul souci était de savoir comment il
garderait le pouvoir. Et donc il n'a
fait aucun découpage homogène.
Le seul moyen qu'avait Moscou de
toujours être présent et de toujours
intervenir, c'était que des découpages
soient hétéroclites. Ce qu'on a fait en
Afrique.
Oui, c'est ce qu'on a fait en Afrique,
mais pas avec la même intention, si tu
veux. Et donc lui, c'était explicite,
c'est-à-dire le régime était parfait,
donc il fallait pouvoir protéger partout
et rappelle-toi quand même qu'il y avait
des populations qui n'avaient jamais
entendu parler de du communisme, du
marxisme. Bon, donc le découpage que
fait Stalin sur lequel va en fite se
faire l'éclatement du RSS, il présente
deux caractéristiques. C'est que les
Russes qui étaient les colonisateurs
deviennent tout à coup minoritaires dans
un pays où les colonisés prennent le
pouvoir.
On a vu ce que ça a donné en Afrique du
Sud.
Ça a vu ce qu'on a donné en Afrique du
Sud. Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est
qu'on l'a pas vu sur les pays les pays
de l'ex URSS. Par exemple, dans les
États-Balles, je crois que c'est en
Lituanie, ils oblige les Russes à une
forte proportion de Russes à parler
parfaitement de Lituanien avant d'avoir
la pass le passeport. Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? C'estàdire, tuas un
renfercement de pouvoir qui est très
fort et qui évidemment est mal accepté
parce eux-mêmes qui étaient les anciens
les anciens leaders, les anciens chefs,
les anciens colonisateurs. Donc deuxème
caractéristique de l'empire, c'est que
c'était un empire dont la colonisation
était la continuité territoriale. C'est
pas comme nous quand on quitte l'Algérie
ou quand on quitte l'Indochine, c'est
fini, on en parle plus. Eux, regardent
le cas de l'Ukraine, c'est la continuité
territoriale. C'està-dire c'est les
parties est de l'Ukraine qui sont au
contact de la Russie. Bon et donc dans
cet éclatement qui a été un séisme
géopolitique gigantesque, que tu puisses
avoir des gens qui disent "Mais
attendez, nous c'est pas ça. Nous on est
toujours on veut toujours être attaché à
la Russie et cetera."
[raclement de gorge] À travers la crise
ukrainienne où Poutine a utilisé un peu
toutes les toutes les bêtises qu'on a
faites, c'est-à-dire l'extension de
l'OTAN, le refus de de dire
explicitement que l'Ukraine
n'appartiendrait pas à l'OTAN, enfin
prendre des engagements fermes si vous
voulez.
On a essayé d'empêcher la crise,
c'est-à-dire français et allemands ont
essayé de négocier ce qu'on appelle les
accords de Minsk, c'est-à-dire en disant
depuis 2014, depuis le moment où les
Russes de la partie S commençai à
s'insurger,
il faut trouver des modalités de respect
de leur culture, de trouver des moyens
de comment dire de coexister et cetera
et cetera. Il y a eu deux accords de
Minsk. En fait, ces accords de ministes
n'ont jamais empêché que la guerre
continue sur la partie est de l'Ukraine.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu quand même
14000 morts à la frontière de l'Ukraine.
On peut pas dire qu'ils sont morts du
choléra, ils sont morts parce que la
guerre continuaite. Donc la
responsabilité de Kief, si tu veux dans
l'entretien de la guerre,
on comprend très bien queils veuillent
ne pas qu'ils ne veuillent pas voir une
partie de leur territoire faire
sécession. Mais en même temps, tu peux
comprendre l'autre côté, c'est-à-dire
des types qui disaient "Mais nous, on ne
respecte pas nos droits." L'Ukrainien
effectivement, c'est la langue officiel
mais c'est l'exclusion de du russe qui
était la langue jusque-là acceptée. Bon,
donc si tu veux, ces brimades
successives, on fait la suite de
l'histoire que tu connais. C'est-à-dire
qu'au bout d'un certain temps, ces
gens-là vont considérer que ils sont
dans c en état de sécession
insurrectionnelle, quoi. Donc derrière
le cas de l'Ukraine, tu as maintenant le
problème de tous ces Russes qui sont
hors de la Russie et dans des situations
complètement différentes. Autant
vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine, on est
directement mobilisé, mais je te dis
l'exemple de l'autre communauté russe
qui est au Kazakhstan. Si demain Poutine
considère queil a pas gagné en Ukraine
et qu'il peut gagner au Kasacan, on
n'est plus du tout dans un système de
garantie internationale comme ça avait
été le cas avec le cas de l'Ukraine.
Toute cette frustration, il y a pas il y
a pas dans les corps diplomatiques, il y
a pas des adultes qui gèrent un peu les
choses. Il y a pas il y a pas des gens
qui disent voilà mais vous savez, vous
allez créer de la de la frustration chez
les gens qui restent. Vous savez, c'est
pas très bien les les répercussions sur
le moyen long terme, ça va créer ça, ça
il y a pas des adultes qui leur parlent
un petit peu où ils sont tous va en
guerre, on interdit les chats russes, on
interdit les sportifs russes.
Mais là, tu parles de qui ? Des
décideurs ou tu parles de cette
communauté des militaraux intellectuels
?
Tous.
Non, parce que le décideur lui, il sait
que les champs russes et des choses
comme ça. On se rend bien compte que
derrière il va y avoir un retour de
flamme qui va être terrible.
Les bon, on s'est jamais trouvé. me en
tout cas pour l'OTAN dans
compris chez les Russes les Ukrain qui
vivent en Russie
pardon
y compris chez les Ukrain qui vivent en
Russie.
Ah oui parce que si tu veux le la de
l'URSS donc qui était un état fédéral
faisait que quand tu étais russe et que
tu étais marié avec une ukrainienne, tu
vivais indifféremment en Ukraine ou en
Russie et si tu t'es marié avec une
casaque et cetera et cetera. Bon donc le
problème posé par l'éclatement et puis
surtout par le dessin de ces frontières
administratives devenues frontières
internationales est gigantesque. On
avait connu qu'un seul précédent,
c'était de la Yougoslavie. La
Yougoslavie, il y avait un personnage
qui s'appelait Tito. Donc lui, c'était
pas question de discuter, mais il avait
conçu la Youoslavie de façon à ce qu'il
y a une espèce d'état tampon entre les
deux entités qui étaient les entités
bellicistes qui étaient les Croates et
les Serbes. Et il avait donc constitué
la Bosnière zeggovine en disant bah ça
c'est les c'est les locaux musulmans. Et
ça devait être l'État tampon qui en
faisant que dans le système des six ou
sep États composant la Yougoslavie, il y
aurait toujours un espèce d'état balance
si tu veux qui ferait voter les choses
dans un sens ou dans l'autre. Bon, ça
n'a pas empêché le drame qui a été la
surgoslavie, c'est que finalement on a
eu cette guerre civile effroyable où il
y a eu les massacres, il y a eu les
viols, il y a eu les camps de
concentration et cetera. Donc on avait
ce précédent de l'éclatement de ces
États fédéraux nés après 1918. Après
1918, rappelle-toi quand on constitue la
Yougoslavie, c'est-à-dire le pays des
slaves du sud, on s'est dit "Regez, ils
vont vivre ensemble." Bon, ils avaient
déjà commencé un peu se massacrer dans
l'entre de guerre. Ils avaient profité
de l'arrivée des Allemands et cetera.
Bon, donc quand Tito arrive, lui on
plaisante pas. Il est croate, il est
communiste, ça marche. Bon, mais dès
qu'il meurt, ça va se déliter. Puis
ensuite, il va y avoir la guerre civile
et puis finalement la constitution
d'État indépendants. Aujourd'hui, il y a
six ou sep États indépendants. Moi, donc
on savait que ces États fédéraux, enfin
on savait arriver à imaginer à l'époque
de de la Yougoslavie que la Suite serait
aussi dramatique pour la Russie. On
pouvait toujours le dire mais enfin ça
faisait un peu mage d'astrologie quoi.
Là on se trouve face au problème
effectivement et même si tu l'avais
écrit à l'époque de Sarayevau, personne
te dit "Attendez, on a suffisamment de
problèmes avec Sarayevo, allez pas nous
nous expliquer comment ça va se passer
en Ukraine." Mais par contre que cette
dynamique si tu veux qui a été celle de
la gestion de la décomposition de
l'URSS, oui, là il y a eu une erreur
politique, c'est-à-dire on a privilégié
la démarche sécuritaire par rapport à la
démarche diplomatique. On a été comme en
1918 quand on a dit l'Allemagne payera.
Là, on a dit ils nous ont fait tellement
peur que c'est les Russes qui pont. Ils
ont effectivement payé. C'est-à-dire,
ils ont connu comme les Allemands dans
les années dans les années 20 la crise
économique dramatique. Les mecs le roue
valait plus rien. Ils étaient obligés
d'aller au marché pour faire du troc.
Enfin bon et en plus ils avaient un chef
d'état qui était un Ivrogne.
Euh et cette Ivrogne là c'est lui qui va
dire "Oui, ils m'ont dit quelque chose
les occidentaux mais enfin bon leur
faire confiance." Poutine va arriver
en promettant qu'il rétablit l'ordre et
une des premières mesures qu'il prend,
c'est de lutter contre les oligarques,
c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont pill à
l'époque de Yalsin, il va commencer par
les mettre en tole, enfin un certain
nombre parce qu'il faut donner l'exemple
mais en même temps, il faut pas les
faire fuir. Donc il va attraper
Kodorkovski qui était le jeune
milliardaire de 25 ans qui avait
simplement c'était simplement approprié
le pétrole.
C'est intéressant. Il y a des gens qui
découvrent du pétrole en creusant. lui,
il avait carrément
pris le la firme Yokol. Bon, donc tu te
retrouves avec un mec qui va lutter
contre ses ses oligarques, en tout cas
pour établir son propre pouvoir. Mais ce
qui est amusant, c'est que Kodorkovski
qui était finalement un pourri quand
même, il faut bien le reconnaître, il va
y avoir quand même des gens qui vont
élever la voie pour le défendre en
disant attention, il faut lui garantir
un procès objectif.
Il y a des moments on ferait mieux de
fermer sa gueule quand même hein. Bon,
faut
toujours un procès objectif. Oui, il
faut toujours effectivement montrer que
la justice des autres n'est pas une
justice respectueuse des droits de
l'homme. Bon bref, donc Poutine fait ce
travail et il attend justement des
occidentaux un certain nombre de
concessions, de postures et cetera qui
vont l'aider à remettre son pays sur
pied. Or sait pas ce qui va se passer.
Et quand il nous avertit à la Vercoun 2
dans qui est une grande séance qui se
passe à Munich il y a 2 3 ans de dire
attention attention vous avez tendu
l'OTAN, vous êtes en train de comment
dire de de l'ouvoyer à propos de
l'Ukraine et cetera, il avertit
mais on se dit bah attends il va pas
faire la bêtise d'eux. Et tu vois bien
que 90 % des gens avant l'invasion de
l'Ukraine pensaient que Poutine ne
ferait pas la bêtise d'eux. Or il l'a
faite. Donc il faut essayer de
comprendre pourquoi il l'a faite.
Il faut essayer de comprendre pourquoi
ils ont pas anticipé.
Oui, mais encore une fois,
pourquoi ils ont pas anticipé ?
Parce que ils vont jamais sur place, ils
parlent pas la langue, ils connaissent
personne. Ils ont appris le pays dans
des livres qui ont été écrits par les
mêmes clones queux. Ça ça vient de quoi
? Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? Alors, on on va
recentrer que sur nous les Français.
Pourquoi nous les Français on est devenu
complètement
aveugle, [raclement de gorge] voire
borne dans le meilleur des cas qu'on on
a plus de souveraineté en terme de
politique extérieure, on est suiviste,
on se fait abreuver de de renseignements
qui viennent même plus de nos nos
propres tuyaux d'information. Et c'est
ça vient de quoi ? Et et et maintenant
en plus on est remplacé par des
intellectuels médiatiques qui ont plus
d'informations que tout le monde.
Mais la majeure partie ils ont l'air de
se planter.
Ils prétendent qu'ils ont plus
d'informations que tout le monde. Mais
je reviens sur cet exemple de ce chef
d'étatmajor de l'armée de l'air. Lui il
savait ce que c'était que l'armée
libienne. Donc la question c'est pas ce
qu'il a pu expliquer où il a pu dire
attention faut pas faire ça.
L'importance encore une fois c'était que
médiatiquement
politiquement on avait un chef d'état
qui s'est dit tiens c'est l'occasion
d'avoir une grande victoire diplomatique
pour la France et donc ça s'est traduit
par ce mandat d'interdiction de survol
aérien qui s'est transformé par une
mission de bombardement au sol bon donc
tu vois le glissement n'est pas une
espèce de comment dire de c'est un
espèce de de processus par étape hein et
puis finalement au bout du compte quand
Kaddafi est lâché ben on se dit ben
après tout c'est un dictateur de moi sur
la planète ce qui va suivre est pire que
ce qu'il y avait avec Kaddafi. Mais
encore une fois, on arrête les compteurs
à ce momentl, on dit "Bon, c'est pas
grave, nous ça nous concerne plus." Donc
je suis pas
je suis pas du tout dans une lecture
mécanique, tu vois, de la façon dont les
décisions se prennent parce qu'encore
une fois, elles sont ponctuées par des
échéances électorales, par des majorités
parlementaires, par des interpellations
sur plateau télé, par des actions de des
grands discours
de de ces différentes strates du
complexe militaire ou intellectuel. Et
effectivement, comme il n'y a plus de
paradigme structurant,
comme il y a plus l'URSS, tu peux dire
"Ben tiens, je vais peut-être aller
faire un petit tour, faire une
intervention en Somalie ou je vais
peut-être aller faire un petit tour en
je sais pas moi, en Afrique." Tu sais,
dans les 30 interventions dont je te
parlais, ça a quand même tourné les
affaires africaines, he c'est-à-dire
qu'on a fait pas mal d'interventions
encore une fois en Afrique.
regarde la situation et les effets
indirects de la destruction du régime de
Kaddafi
pardon.
Commençons déjà par Saddam Hussein. Les
généraux de Saddam Hussein, ils sont
partis où ? Les généraux de de Kaddafi
sont partis où ? Les armes sont parties
où ? Elles sont parties se disséminer où
ça en Afrique ? Elles sont restées sur
zone. Elles ont été revendues une fois,
deux fois, trois fois.
Alors
c'est intéressant ta question parce que
tous ces conflits se sont faits sans
apparition des marchands d'armes. La
Yugoslavie c'est un concept de défense
populaire tu connais c'était l'idée de
la résistance qui avait battu les
Allemands et cetera et cetera. Donc
finalement il y avait beaucoup d'armes.
Il y avait des stocks d'armes. Et la
guerre en Yougoslavie s'est faite sans
queil y ait des acteurs extérieurs qui
apportent des des des armes aux uns et
aux autres.
[raclement de gorge]
tu te retrouves dans la même situation
effectivement en Russie, c'est-à-dire
que il y a pas un concept de défense
populaire, mais il y a de toute façon
chacun des des pays membres si tu veux
avait quand même une certaine autorité
militaire. Bon et donc le on n'est plus
dans des guerres où les marchandames
viennent avec leur petites valises si tu
veux pour dire nous avons du missile,
nous avons du c, nous avons du ça,
qu'est-ce que vous voulez ? On est dans
un système où le
ce sont [grognement] les États qui vont
considérer que l'exportation d'armes est
un acte politique éventuellement gratuit
d'ailleurs parce que quand tu veux
sauver un pays, il faut mais sur le
cadre de la de l'Irak, le cas d'Irak est
plus intéressant que peut-être celui de
l'Ukraine. Pourquoi ?
Bon l'Irak c'est un très bon client hein
pour nous. respect à à la mémoire de
Saddam Hussein. Donc il avait à peu près
tout acheté hein.
Quand il y a la révolution iranienne,
révolution populaire s'il en est hein,
on peut pas discuter. 2 millions de
personnes qui attendent Roménie quand il
débarquent de l'avion d'Air France. Tu
sais qu'on craignait que on craignait
que l'avion France, on lui a fait faire
un immense détour pour pas qu'il survole
l'Irak parce qu'on s'est dit le jour où
les iraakiens balance un missile sur
l'avion d'Air France, on sera vraiment
dans la panade. Bref, toujours est-il
que quand il arrive à Teran 2 millions
de personnes qui viennent d'attendre à
l'aéroport, tu peux considérer que c'est
une manifestation populaire. Bon et donc
après Roméni un mec qui avait quand même
vécu en Irak pendant 20 ans. Il était
passé par Paris. On avait proposé
gentiment d'ailleurs au chat d'Iran de
dire écoutez s'il vous embête en Irak
nous on va le prendre chez nous, on va
le mettre la nofre le château, on va le
contrôler et cetera et cetera.
Proposition de Ponatovski.
Effectivement, il vient en France et on
dit au Chadiran vous inquiétez pas,
celui-là on le surveille et cetera. Le
personnage était beaucoup plus retort et
beaucoup plus futé que ce qu'on
imaginait. C'était un vieux monsieur. On
se disait que lui il était complètement
dans la religion. Tu parles à Nof le
château, les mecs défilés, c'est-à-dire
toute l'opposition iranienne va arriver
en France pour rencontrer le futur
leader. Et donc finalement, on va
s'apercevoir que non seulement les
manifestations ne s'arrêtent pas à
Teran, mais que finalement on a une
espèce de de cadeau pourri, c'est-à-dire
qu'on a Roménie. Bref, on va négocier le
fait qu' qu'il va retourner là-bas. Donc
processus avec l'avion d'Air France, ce
que je vous racontais et le chat d'Iran
se barre parce qu'il se rend compte
qu'effectivement il maîtrise plus la
situation. Bon, mais tu maîtrises pas
une révolution, tu le sais bien, on l'a
vécu nous avec la révolution française.
Donc les étudiants révolutionnaires, ils
vont attaquer l'ambassade des
États-Unis. C'était le diable en plein
cœur de Tréran les États-Unis. Et donc
ils vont
trouver d'ailleurs du super matos.
Alors attends parce que l'histoire est
assez ridicule c'est assez rigolote.
Donc ils envahissent l'état, ils font
prisonnier un certain nombre de
diplomates, ils vont les ils vont
prendre des otages, je sais plus combien
il y en avait mais enfin donc ils
violent la convention de Vienne qui
garantit le statut des diplomates en
poste à l'étranger. Mais en même temps,
les diplomates, sentant que ça tournait
mal, si tu veux, avait commencé à
déchiqueter tous les papiers
compromettants qu'il y avait dans
l'ambassade parce que il y avait des
papiers compromettants si tu veux sur
toutes les interventions et les
ingérences qu'avaient fait les
Américains dans la vie politique à
l'époque du chat. Bon et donc ils vont
récupérer tous les les sacs poubelles
avec tous les morceaux de papier
déchiqueté et cetera. Ils vont les
confier à des tisseuses de ta fille, tu
vois des filles, des petites mains qui
vont reconstituer les documents,
certains des documents. Ils vont publier
ces documents montrant que le l'Amérique
n'avait cessé d'intervenir dans la vie
politique iranienne. Et donc tu te dis
lequel des deux est en violation du
droit international ? Celui qui prend
des diplomates en otage ou celui qui se
mêle continuellement de la vie politique
? Mais tu comprends bien que pour nous
occidentaux c'était évidemment la prise
en otage des diplomates. Bon donc le
camarade Saddam Hussein qui sent une
opportunité assez fantastique parce
qu'il avait perdu la guerre précédente à
l'époque du chat fait le tour des
capitales européennes pour leur dire
écoutez moi je vais m'en charger de
Saddam Hussein simplement faut que vous
me garantissiez que vous me fournissez
des armes. Et effectivement il va
déclencher le conflit et c'est donc un
des rares conflits dans lequel on va
soutenir l'agresseur et on va mettre
sous embargot l'agressé.
Tu veux que je la recommence doucement
ou c'est pas la peine ? Donc c'est une
guerre dans laquelle on va mettre sous
embargot l'agressé et on va fournir
toutes les armes possible à Saddam
Hussein, y compris des navigateurs sur
des super étendards qu'on va prendre
dans les ranges de l'armée française
parce que la guerre des pétroliers
nécessite que et cetera. C'est-à-dire
que tu vois jusqu'où on a poussé encore
une fois quand tu poses ta question de
la rationalité, il y a personne qui les
conseille. Non, il y a une mécanique qui
au bout d'un certain temps si tu veux
devient folle. Si tu cesses de financer
et de fournir des armes à celui que tu
soutiens et qui perds la guerre, tu
perds tes armes et ton pognon. Donc tu
vois, il y a un cercle vicieux, il
fallait toujours monter en grade dans la
fourniture. Et pour les Iraniens, c'est
un martyrologue.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ne comprennent pas
pourquoi ils sont sous embargot. Ils
sont obligés d'utiliser des jeunes qui
vont passer sur les champs de mines
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de détecteur de
mines pour faire sauter les mines pour
que les combattants passent.
Donc quand tu vois dans un cimetière,
c'est c'est assez impressionnant les
cimetières parce que tu as le cimetière
des martyres évidemment, mais surtout tu
as des pierres tombales avec la photo du
mec.
Donc le mec te regarde d'où tombe.
Tu comprends mieux si tu veux à ce
moment-là pourquoi les Iraniens ils
l'ont un peu un travers de la gorge.
Parce que tous ces jeunes qui sont
morts, c'est à cause de not de notre
manière de gérer cette crise là.
Et donc on est sur quelque chose où tu
te rends compte que effectivement si tu
ne comprends pas comment l'autre
fonctionne, si tu te rends pas compte de
tes propres responsabilités, ben tu te
restes toujours dans le camp du bien.
C'est évident, tu es toujours le mec qui
a décidé de pour le l'avenir de
l'humanité de faire une guerre. Bon donc
voilà, c'est pour ça que ce complexe
évidemment l'Iran fait partie de ces
sujets si tu veux qui dans les dans
lesquels se délectent si tu veux les ce
complexe militaire intellectuel.
Épisode intéressant. Par exemple, euh je
sais plus quand c'était euh madame
Badinter lance une pétition un jour pour
essayer de sauver une jeune fille qui
s'appelait Jihad Hilali, je crois
quelque chose comme ça de 13 ans qui
devait être lapidée en Iran.
condamnation à la lapidation. Bon, elle
avait été violée par son frère mais
enfin son frère avait reçu ses coups de
fouet le contingent prévu pour les coups
de fouet quand il viole une fille mais
elle par contre qu'elle était pas nature
impure c une femme donc elle allait être
lapidée pétition qui circule à toute
vitesse dans Saint-Germain desprè je te
retrouvais la liste des signataires
parce que évidemment tu as tout le
gratin de Saint-Germain des Prê qui va
s'élever contre cette condamnation
scandaleuse.
Le K d'orsier évidemment est ému. Donc
il appelle l'ambassadeur sur place. Il y
a même un membre de la comment dire de
l'administration de l'Union européenne
qui va à Teran qui pose la question les
Iraniens disent non il y a pas eu de
condamnation à la lapidation mais enfin
la machine était lancée donc la pétition
continue à circuler et cetera donc le qu
d'ors fait une première communiquée avec
son porte-parole disant nous n'avons
aucune information sur cette personne.
On sait que la circulation l'information
a circulé mais comme la pétition
continue à circuler, ils font une
deuxième mission à Teran et Teran leur
dit non, il y a pas eu de condamnation à
lapidation. Donc le Kedorsier refait un
deuxième point presse en disant non, il
y a pas de condamnation. Cette jeune
fille n'a pas été condamnée à la
lapidation. Je sais pas ce qui lui est
arrivé. Enfin bref, mais en tout cas
c'est pas le scénario qui a donné lieu à
la pétition.
Après ça, ça s'arrête. Personne ne
publie le démenti du Kedoré, ni le
démenti de l'ambassade d'Iran. elle qui
avait fait des grosses couvertures, le
journal, elle qui avait fait des sujets
là-dessus, pas de on publie pas le truc.
C'est-à-dire que tu vas pas dire que
tous ces gens-là qui sont la gratin de
la société française
se sont trompés, se sont laissés enfumer
à ce point-là. Mais tu vois comme la
cause est belle, une jeune fille de 13
ans qui va être lapidée, est-ce que tu
résisterais à une pétition là-dessus ?
Tu vois, donc tuas si tu as un bon sujet
d'ennemis comme ça, de méchants, tu peux
faire passer ce que tu veux.
les les petits cours d'autodéfense
intellectuelle de notre communauté,
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour être
plus résilient face à ça ?
Écoute, [raclement de gorge]
c'est une très bonne question là. Nous
nous on l'a vu on l'a vu avec le le dans
notre communauté dans au départ au
départ de du conflit ukrainien avec la
guerre en Ukraine. Hm
hm.
L'île du serpent.
Ouais.
Donc paraît-il qu'il en restait que
trois ou quatre qu'ils ont fait acte de
bravoure ? Ils ont dit aux russes
d'aller se faire en papauté bien
profond.
Derrière
les médias nous ont dit qu'il s'était
fait raser raser entièrement l'île. Bon
résultat des courses, ils étaient pas
morts. Il y en avait pas que cinq, ils
étaient 80. les Russes les ont récupéré
et ça a continué comme ça. Nous, on l'a
vu tout de suite notre communauté dire
"Attendez, on va attendre que ça se
délaye un petit peu." Qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire ? Il faut prendre son temps,
avoir plusieurs sources, trianguler
l'information, avoir des sources sur
place. Comment on fait pour être plus
résilient face à ça ? Comment on fait
pour pas se faire emmener à la guerre ?
Ah
oui,
côté comme dans l'autre. Bon,
il reste un fait l'invasion est russe.
Pas discuter là-dessus. C'est un une
décision unilatérale de Moscou de faire
rentrer ses troupes. Ils avaient déjà
soutenu militairement les
sécessionnistes du Donbas et du Donnet.
Mais en tout cas là, il y a une
invasion.
Alors
encore une fois, moi ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est ça fait une trentaine d'années que
je m'occupe de différents types de
conflits, si tu veux et encore une fois,
ce qui m'intéresse, c'est à la limite
moins la guerre que la façon dont on
raconte la guerre. Tu comprends bien ce
que je veux dire par le complexe MARO
intellectuel
reprend le déroulé de la guerre. le plan
de Poutine. Alors Poutine, il dit qu'il
veut négocier quelques une semaine avant
que l'invasion ne se déclenche. Donc on
peut considérer que l'individu est un
peu un bâton merdeux quand même. C'est
pas un type à qui on peut faire toute
confiance. Il a prévu un plan d'invasion
ce qu'il y a en face aussi.
Attends attends attends attends. Oui
mais lui si tu veux il faut quand même
aussi lui faire sa part de de critique.
Il fait un plan d'invasion avec cinq
axes de pénétration sur l'Ukraine dont
un qui devait aller à Kief.
Donc on voit que son intention était pas
de défendre le Donetsk. c'était
effectivement de prendre K manque de
chance ça marche pas. Bon ça marche pas
et finalement il va être obligé de sur
aucun des axes de pénétration ça ne va
marcher. Sauf qu'il va tout rapatrier
sur la partie est pour finalement dire
mais en fait mon intention depuis le
départ c'était de défendre les les
russophones. Quoi ?
Donc tu te retrouves dans une situation
où effectivement euh
tu as menteur menteur et demi parce que
si il y avait 13000 morts à la ligne
frontière entre le Donetz et Donbas et
le reste de l'Ukraine, c'est que la
guerre avait continué. Donc que tous les
efforts diplomatiques qu'avaaient fait
français et allemands avec les accords
de Minsk pour dire trouvons une solution
diplomatique si tu veux l'Ukraine
elle-même n'avait pas joué le jeu. Alors
sur les 13000, il y a moitié ukrainien
moitié sécessionniste.
Oui mais ça te prouve que c'était un
conflit intense.
C'est-à-dire qu'effectivement il y avait
du bombardement, il y avait des gens qui
mouraient et cetera. Même si ça s'étale
sur plusieurs années, ça veut dire que
les formules diplomatiques n'avaient pas
marché. Bon donc quand Poutine
finalement décide l'invasion, il a le
tort d'avoir fait l'invasion encore une
fois. Mais alors deuxème question, tu te
dis mais pourquoi il a il s'est arrêté à
Kiev ? Pourquoi il a jamais pu prendre
Kiev ? Tu t'aperçois deuxème aspect de
la question que l'armée rouge qu'on
avait présenté comme un espèce de
monstre omnipotent, une espèce de
rouleau compresseur et cetera n'était
pas déjà à l'époque des communistes ce
monstre qu'on croyait. Épisode vécu
l'Afghanistan.
Les Russes envahissent l'Afghanistan 79
et donc je suis sûr qu'il y a des
généraux russes qui ont dit au chef de
l'époque, je sais plus si c'était Brejf,
vous inquiétez pas chef, on va vous
faire la chose vite fait.
10 ans et ils vont partir la queue entre
les jambes. Ils vont partir la queue
entre les jambes avec plusieurs constats
qui avaient déjà été fait par des gens
qui suivaient l'Afghanistan qui allaient
sur place qui faisaient des évaluations,
c'est que l'armée rouge souffrait de
déficit structurel d'intendance. Les
mecs recevaient des des rations à
varier. Les appelés n'avaient aucune
envie de se battre et cetera et cetera.
Donc si tu veux quand tu es dans cette
situation et on est en pleine guerre
froide, va expliquer au complexe
militaire ou intellectindustriel
occidental
que son ennemi n'est pas celui qu'on
présente. Tu te retournes avec des gens
qui disent "Écoutez mon cher ami, euh
allez raconter ça à vos petits
camarades, mais laissez-nous gérer les
affaires du complexe militaro industriel
quoi."
Donc on savait que ce cette armée avait
des difficultés gigantesques et
effectivement ils vont se retirer
en 89 euh sur un bilan assez dramatique.
Les Américains les ont bien aidés. Oui,
mais justement ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que l'Afghanistan comme l'avait
appelé l'autre, c'est le tombeau des
empires. Ils avaient gonflé les
Britanniques à la belle époque, ils ont
gonflé les Russes à la belle époque. Et
ben les Américains vont dire "Non, non,
mais nous l'Afghanistan, vous allez
voir, on va vous faire ça vite fait,
bien fait chef." Et ils ont fait
exactement comme les autres.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils se sont heurtés à
une un pays dont la caractéristique
majeure, c'est que c'est une zone, ce
qu'on appelle en géopolitique une zone
de confin, c'est-à-dire c'est une région
montagneuse dans laquelle se sont
réfugiés des tas de populations
hétéroclites qui étaient pour chassé par
les empires. Donc ça veut dire que dans
une vallée d'Afghanistan, tu as pas la
même ethnique dans la vallée à côté que
le chef de guer celui-là, il est pas
obligé d'être d'accord avec le chef
là-bas et cetera. Et donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut que tu conquieres tout. tu
vas pas prendre la capitale, ça sert à
rien. Et donc, ils vont se retrouver
dans le même scénario que ce qu'ont
connu les Anglais, que ce qu' ont connu
les Russes et cetera, c'est-à-dire une
guerre de résistance.
Un chef de guerre afghan qui disait une
phrase que je trouve délicieuse. Il
disait "On peut pas acheter un chef de
guerre afghan.
On peut le louer
mais on peut le louer." Bon et donc tu
as toute la problématique d'ailleurs en
Afghanistan. Donc finalement les les
Américains sont obligés également de se
retirer encore une fois avec un bilan
désastreux au point que ce sont les
Talibans qui reviennent.
Alors justement, je reviens à ta
question, mais il y a pas un mec qui
leur a dit "Vous savez, l'Afghanistan
est un pays musulman ? Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? C'est pas parce que tu
arrives en libérateur avec du Coca-Cola
et avec des chewing-gumin
les Afghans qui sont depuis des années,
si tu veux dans la dans la dans cette
culture. Alors, il y a un épisode qui
est délicieux, c'est que quand ça
commençait à caler l'invasion
américaine, à ce moment-là, on dit "Oui,
mais attendez, on va libérer la femme
afghane." C'était quand même un beau
projet.
École pour les petites filles.
Pardon ? Les écoles pour les petites
filles.
Les écoles pour les petites filles. Bon
mais tu vas raconter un afghan
traditionnel d'une campagne que tu vas
libérer sa femme et sa fille, mais le
mec il devient taliban. Tu vois ce que
je veux dire ? Donc le l'adéquation
entre l'objectif politique, la méthode
militaire a abouti à cette catastrophe
qu'on connaît. C'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui les talibans sont là puis
il disent non les femmes à l'école c'est
de la connerie. Ça c'est des trucs des
inventions de d'occidental. Bon donc
avant de faire ce tu devrais faire ce
retour en arrière justement te disant
mais pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
que l'outil militaire était le meilleur
moyen de résoudre cette crise ? Mais en
même temps, quand tu as derrière toi des
gens qui te disent notamment ce complexe
militar intellectuel, mais enfin vous ne
pouvez pas ne pas vous rendez compte la
situation des femmes en Afganissan, tu
donnes satisfaction aux féministes
américaines.
C'est de l'emploi. Vous allez sacrifier
de l'emploi.
Ah oui, ça c'est une autre question.
Mais enfin bon, c'est pas très
consommateur les guerres comme celle-là.
Revenons, revenons à l'Ukraine.
Ouais.
Ça va s'arranger, ça va pas s'arranger.
La boule de cristal bou pas le bout de
de cristal. Les objectifs qu'il y a
derrière
de qui ? de Poutine. Alors certes,
protéger la veuve et l'orphelin qui
parle russe avec des chats russes et ils
seront tous russes dans un pays russe.
Donc ça c'est ce qui nous est présenté
de leur côté des nazifiés et j' passé
des meilleurs. Bon les les vrais
objectifs c'est quoi ?
C'est sécuriser 5 % du marché
alimentaire mondial c'est avoir un
levier de pression c'est éviter que
l'OTAN mette la main en face. que les
politiques raisonnent à cette échéance
là, tu sais, pour les avoir vécu d'assez
près. Non, non, non. C'est quel est le
gain immédiat ? pas la perspective à
long terme. Euh, tu citais un exemple
nous emmener là,
tu sais où ça va nous emmener. Si ce que
tu dis est vrai,
ouais,
c'estàd que si notre corps diplomatique
c'est une bande de bougeux dans un salon
feutré avec 4 cm de moquette, qu'ils ont
rien fait depuis un certain nombre
d'années, que Macron leur a volé dans
les plumes parce que bon, il fallait
quand même les secouer les vieux
poulets. Si c'est le cas,
quand tu quand tu raisonnes à plus long
terme, même à moyen terme, allez à 7 10
ans.
Ouais.
Ça va être un [__] de bourbier.
Écoute, il y [raclement de gorge] a
plusieurs choses dans ta question. Le
corps diplomatique est composé de gens
intelligent, formé, cultivé,
mais c'est une mécanique qui ne fait que
très rarement remonter au sommet des
informations désagréables.
Très rarement. Bah pourquoi ? Parce que
si tu dis "Écoutez, je suis dans une
région du monde où tout le monde se fout
de ce que Paris va décider ou si tu dis
excusez-moi, on est en train de se
tromper,
ta carrière chancelle hein. Donc on fait
des télégrammes diplomatiques où on dit
mais en fait faire voilà, j'avais un
copain qui me disait, il était directeur
Asie, il me disait mais moi je lisais
dans les dépêches à FP le soir ce que
j'allais trouver dans les télégrammes
diplomatiques le lendemain.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est-à-dire la lenteur de la mécanique
qui est dorsé par rapport à la dynamique
du de de la FP. Bon, donc tu te
retrouves avec des gens qui sont en
charge de quelque chose mais dont le
mandat bride la liberté d'interprétation
et la liberté d'action. Bon, donc c'est
pas la question du qu d'oré seulement,
c'est que encore une fois, c'est à Paris
que les choses se décident. Surtout si
tu ne sais tu sais qu'il n'aura pas une
puissance étrangère qui va
instrumentaliser ton truc. Donc tu as à
Paris des gens qui vont te dire "Non,
non, mais l'Afghanistan, je connais
bien, je j'ai passé une semaine." Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? tu vas te
retrouver avec des gens qui à cause de
cette présence médiatique de cette
emprise germanopratine vont accéder à
des plateaux télés qui interpellent
directement le politique. Et le
politique, qu'est-ce qu'il intéresse ?
Bah ça à la limite s'en fout que les les
Afghans que les femmes afghanes se
fassent emprisonner. Ce qui l'intéresse,
c'est qu'est-ce que la valeur symbolique
et électorale de ma décision. Voilà.
Donc euh si effectivement tu as
l'impression que interpellé par un homme
qui rentre de sur place et qui va dire
euh mais non, il faut faire quelque
chose et cetera, que tu ne fais rien,
ben tu apparaît comme une lavette, tu
vois.
Alors côté côté population, nous
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ? Il faut
qu'on lise plus, faut qu'on s'intéresse
plus à la géopolitique, il faut qu'on
complète notre prisme de lecture,
il faut démystifier le le la diplomatie,
il faut la plus ou ou où ou inversement
la mettre sur un piédestal.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire en en terme
concret pour éviter de se faire mener
par le bout du nez en fonction des
intérêts de X ou Y ? Écoute, d'abord la
première chose qui me frappe dans ta
question,
c'est qu'on appartient tous et vous
encore plus que moi parce que moi je
suis déjà un peu ancien. C'est que on
voyage,
tu vois la différence ? C'est-à-dire que
moi je suis de la génération des
routards si tu veux. C'est-à-dire
l'époque où effectivement on pouvait
traverser le Moyen-Orient sans risquer
sa peau, ce qui était effectivement une
géopolitique tout à fait différente.
Mais je veux dire les la génération qui
suit sont des gens qui évidemment
s'intéressent au monde parce que le
monde n'est pas comme eux. Donc déjà
c'est un énorme acquis.
[raclement de gorge]
Deuxième chose, évidemment, s'intéresser
à la au mode de pensée des autres,
c'est-à-dire de pas prendre comme
référence son propre mode de pensée pour
expliquer que l'autre est dans le tort.
C'est une manière d'essayer de
comprendre si tu veux pourquoi l'autre
qui après tout aussi rationnel que nous
peut avoir une un point de vue
totalement différent sur le même
phénomène.
Le ce qui me frappe aujourd'hui, c'est
que dans ma génération la grande
question c'était la fin dans le monde.
Bon ça ça a été en partie résolue.
La nre c'est la fin du monde. Alors, il
y a effectivement la fin du monde, mais
tu t'aperçois que pendant cette décennie
91, donc avec la multiplicité de ces
interventions militaires, la destruction
des pays du Moyen-Orient et cetera,
aujourd'hui on parle au nom de la
communauté internationale en disant il
faut mettre Poutine sous embargot
international
et tu as des pays, la moitié de
l'humanité ou les trois quarts de
l'humanité qui sont la Chine, l'Inde,
l'Indonésie, [raclement de gorge]
le Brésil qui disent "Non, attendez, ça
c'est pas notre guerre, c'est la votre".
C'est-à-dire qu'on a plus le droit de
parler de la communauté à la place de la
communauté internationale et ça c'est
une transformation fondamentale. Est-ce
que tu vas arriver à convaincre les
décideurs ? Ça je suis pas sûr qu'ils
vont changer de de discours, mais tu
comprends que cette légitimité tirée de
91 c'était de se dire "Mais nous sommes
la communauté internationale. On
s'aperçoit avec la crise de l'Ukraine
que nous ne sommes plus la communauté
internationale." Donc tu as vu le voyage
du sénégalais là de qui est allé à
Moscou pour dire "Attendez, nous on a
besoin ma population et cetera." Et donc
tu te dis mais le Sénégal comment la
France au Sénégal ? Non. Ce type affirme
son identité en disant moi je ne veux
pas subir les effets d'une guerre qui
n'a pas été déclenché par nous et qui ne
nous concerne pas.
Faut dire qu'il y a il y a Wagner sur
son territoire et qu'il est aidé pour
ses projets.
Non. Ouais. Pas au Sénégal. Pas au
Sénégal. Mais même prends Wagner. Prends
Wagner. Bon, Wagner c'est la nouvelle
thématique pour montrer le caractère
diabolique des Russes.
Bon, excepter le fait que Wagner nous a
chassé du Mali qui est le pays le plus
aidé par la France, tu es quand même en
droit un moment de te demander qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé quoi dans nos relations
avec les Maliens. Mais je laisse ça de
côté. Wagner, c'est une société
militaire privée. Société militaire
privée, c'est un concept qui a été
inventé par les Sud-Africains à la fin
de l'apartaille. Pourquoi ? parce qu'ils
avaient une armée évidemment qui était
surdimensionnée. Donc quand l'apartail
disparaît, que le la crise en Angola ou
Mozambique est résolue et cetera. Donc
ils ont des surffectifs qui vont
transformer en société militaire privée
qui vont intervenir dans des conflits
africains. Bon, le modèle va être repris
par les Britanniques et ensuite par les
Américains.
Les Américains en Irak, il y avait plus
de ce qu'on appelle de contractors que
de soldats réguliers. Ça veut dire que
des pouvoirs régaliens sur place en
plus.
Et donc tu as dans un système si tu veux
qui a été repensé par les autres enfin
réutilisé par les autres mais avec
exactement la même mission que ce que
fait Wagner là-bas. C'est-à-dire ils
vont combattre à la place d'eux.
L'avantage de ces sociétés militaires
privées, tu les comprends bien, quand un
mec est tué, tu vas pas faire une
cérémonie en rentrant avec le drapeau
américain sur son cercueil. Bon, donc tu
vas pas avoir une famille qui va
éplorer, qui va pleurer et cetera. Donc
ça a un avantage important en terme de
mercenariat et d'intervention
extérieure. Donc on veut dire les Wagner
c'est pas bien. Ouais. Simplement il y a
ce passif. Et donc tu t'aperçois que
Black Water en Irak c'était une bande de
voyou.
C'est Black Water qui gère qui a géré
pendant longtemps la prison
cubaine la prison de Guantanamo.
Je dire attends comment ça ils ont géré
la prison de Guantanamo ? Oui, ils on
ils avaient privatisé la gestion de
Guantanamo de tous les prisonniers qui
sont toujours là-bas. J'en profite pour
faire une incidente sur Guantanamo. Il y
a encore une vingtaine de types à
Guantanamo qui depuis 20 ans sont
détenus sans qu'on puisse leur reprocher
juridiquement quoi que ce soit, sans que
les pays dont ils venaient veuillent
bien les récupérer, sans que les
Américains ne veuillent bien les faire
rentrer sur le territoire américain pour
les juger. Je complète ton aparté.
Ouais. Euh nous on a eu les prisons
secrètes en Europe de la CIA.
Oui, c'était la CIA pareil. Oui, oui,
oui, bien sûr, bien sûr,
bien sûr.
Avec des vols qui survolaient notre
territoire européen pour ça, tu peux pas
surveiller ce qu'il y avait dans les
avions quand même.
Mais enfin, c'est vrai que tu as eu tu
as raison. Les présidents de la CIA été
parsemé notamment dans les anciens pays
satellites où effectivement on leur
garantissait que ça poserait pas un
problème d'opinion publique. Ouais.
On fait quoi nous ? Bah écoute,
il faut que la société civile se se
mette autour d'une d'un pôle
anti-guerre. Il faut que la société
civile s'élève contre la guerre, que ce
soit la guerre russe ou la guerreienne,
française, européenne, américaine. Il
faut il faut que la population landa
dise maintenant ça suffit.
Je sais pas, j'ai pas de solution. Je
suis désolé, je vois le système évoluer,
je le vois avoir ses ses succès, ses
échecs,
mais il a il a cette dynamique, qui
continue à fonctionner. Mais
c'est que là, on va au carton là,
pardon.
De ton grand âge.
Ouais,
on va au carton.
Non, je suis pas sûr.
Alors, je te je te je te je te délaye un
peu ton point de vue de boomer.
Là, l'Allemagne se réarme.
Ouais.
L'Allemagne se fait sanctionner.
L'Allemagne n'a plus de gaz.
Ouais.
L'Allemagne réouvre ses centrales à
charbon. Oui, bien sûr.
Donc nous sommes en guerre contre la
Russie, nous sommes en guerre contre le
terrorisme, on n'est pas encore en
guerre contre le réchauffement
climatique.
À côté Poutine, c'est Mickey Mouse.
Oui, mais si tu veux, je vais te prendre
l'exemple pétrolier parce que il est
autant plus rigolo. Il va être
exactement dans le même sens que toi.
Donc les Russes les Russes coupent le
pétrole et le gaz. Donc tu vas chercher
des fournisseurs alternatifs.
Fournisseurs alternatifs, tu vas les
trouver assez facilement. C'est l'Iran,
le Qatar, l'Arabie Saoudite,
[raclement de gorge] le
Nigéria, c'est-à-dire des pays avec
lequel on a imposé des sanctions pour
atteindre des droits de l'homme. Enfin,
pas l'Arabie Saoudite. L'Arabie
Saoudite, il respecte les droits de
l'homme. Enfin, surtout les droits de la
femme. Et donc, tu te dis, tu te rends
compte dans quel dilemme on s'est placé
soi-même, c'est-à-dire, on se dit "Mais
bon, pays d'Asie centrale, c'est pareil,
tu as des gros fournisseurs mais ces
gros fournisseurs les pipes n'existent
pas." Donc on est on va se trouver dans
la dépendance de pays dont on a condamné
la politique sur des raisons
humanitaires. Mais tu penses bien
qu'entre le point d'équilibre de
l'opinion publique française ou
allemande ou espagnole qui veut pas que
son niveau de vie soit trop dégradé, on
va être obligé de marcher sur la tête de
tout de tas de principes de diplomatie
qu'on avait mis en avant si tu veux pour
expliquer notre diplomatie. Donc tu es
coincé entre une réelle politique qui va
s'imposer de fait et puis des principes
dont on discutera en milieu fermé quoi.
Qui sont
oh ben qui sont le respect des droits de
l'homme, le les libertés publiques, des
tas de choses comme ça quoi qui sont
très très intéressantes. Sauf que
effectivement ça marche pas. Écoute, on
est dans un système nous
dans lequel le walkisme et le comment
dire
des grandes tendances qui sont arrivées
des États-Unis sont en train de
s'implanter. Bon, je ne sais dans quelle
ambassade française on a l'ambassadeur
avait affiché le drapeau français, le
drapeau européen et le drapeau
arc-en-ciel.
Les autorités locales ont protesté en
disant c'est inadmissible on n'a pas de
raison d'entrer dans vos revendications
qui sont le droit des gay des bisexuel
des transsexuels et cetera et cetera.
L'autre fois j'étais dans un débat
invité
parce que Macron allait rencontrer
Orbane.
Alors Orban, c'est le chien fou du
système européen puisque il a ses
positions populistes et cetera et
cetera. Et j'avais en face de moi un
type qui justement expliquait que Macron
ne devait pas rencontrer Orban parce que
Urban ne respectait pas toutes ses
pratique sexuelle minoritair si tu veux.
Bon et je lui disais "Mais attendez,
Urban il a été élu deux fois dans des
élections qui n'ont pas été contestées.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'il y a de l'importance
? C'est que ce type soit représentatif
ou qui respecte vos valeurs ?" Tu vois
le le Yatus ?
[raclement de gorge]
Donc Urban, vous en pensez ce que vous
voulez, mais enfin c'est pas le rôle
d'un chef d'état d'aller vérifier si le
chef d'état local, il a respecté le
droit des transgen, le droit des
machins, le droit des machins, le droit
des machins. Tu vois comment
progressivement le discours diplomatique
est influencé par des règles qui sont
justement des membres de plus en plus
actifs de ce complexe militaire
intellectuel. Et alors au bout du
compte, bon, j'étais un peu vache parce
que j'ai dit au type "Mais vous savez
les cul là, ceux qui savent pas s'ils
sont hommes ou femmes, comment vous
faites les recensements
Là, il a trouvé que j'avais violé la
règle du de la bonne conscience.
Mais tu te rends bien compte que il y a
une partie de la planète qui en ont rien
à [__] de ce qu'on est en train
d'expliquer. Quand je disais au type
mais quand Orban est rentré dans l'Union
européenne, personne ne connaissait les
transgenres. Tout à coup, vous mettez
une nouvelle strate en disant "Regarde,
il y a c il y a ça, il y a c il y a ça,
mais de quel droit vous réglementez la
vie internationale ? Il y a des pays
dans lesquels ces problèmes ne sont pas
considérés comme des problèmes majeurs.
Donc, tu peux pas soumettre ta
diplomatie à des tas de critiques comme
celle-là en disant "Oui, mais vous êtes
dans le wisme, vous êtes dans le c, vous
êtes dans le ça." Donc je sais que c'est
ça choque ce que je dis, mais en même
temps, la vie internationale, c'est
aussi le respect de l'autre.
Dans ton bouquin, le dernier, est-ce que
tu voudrais nous lire deux pages ? une
page.
Ben écoute, je vais te lire
l'introduction parce que c'est peut-être
celle qui me vient en tête tout de
suite.
Alors
alors, attends, je vais essayer. Faut
que je trouve le bon endroit.
Pardon.
Pierre est en train de feuilleter son
livre d'une façon très concentrée.
Bah oui, il faut quand même que je fasse
attention à lire le bon passage que je
veux lire.
Tu voudrais pas faire des cassettes pour
Noël ? Oh, si tu veux, on peut faire des
cassettes, cadeau. [rires]
Ah, merde, où est-ce que j'ai mis ce
passage ?
Et donc et donc faire des petites
cassettes à Noël, ce serait bien les
cassettes de Pierre.
Faire des podcasts de Pierre, ce ça
c'est une bonne idée. Est-ce que tu nous
as trouvé ta page ?
Ben non, je vais pas la trouver parce
que malheureusement c'était une page
dans laquelle j'expliquais le
Alors, prends n'importe laquelle. Non.
Bah ouais. Non, je sais mais en même
temps il y a des choses que j'ai déjà
développé et je vais je voudrais trouver
cette page parce que je la trouve.
Alors vas-y, cherche.
C'est la plus rigolot.
Du coup, on va meubler. On va meubler
pendant que tu cherches.
Donc Pierre, attends, je vais voir.
Ça arrive.
Non, mais ça va pas, ça va pas aller. Tu
aurais dû m'avertir avant quoi.
Oui, j'avertis jamais personne.
Un piège ça.
J'avertis. Tu es sûr que c'est toi qui
l'a écrit le livre ?
Ouais. Oui, je suis capable de réciter à
l'endroit et à l'envers comme faisait
Alcofass
Alcofri brass fragilier dans Rabel. Tu
sais, il avait appris à Gargantua.
Allez, prends prends n'importe quel
morceau une page au pif, tu plantes ton
stylo dessus.
Ouais, mais en même temps si tu veux, ça
pas un très grand intérêt comme
si on voudra écouter ta voix suave.
Bon, voilà, je vais te lire un truc là
aussi.
Les guerres humanitaires donc justes,
sont le produit phare du complexe
militaire intellectuel.
adopté en général sous mandat onusien
sur des principes de droit international
de plus en plus contradictoires qui sont
la responsabilité de protéger le droit
d'ingérence humanitaire la présence
armée des casques bleus est supposée non
belligérante.
Ces interventions sont la conjonction
d'agissement d'acteurs connus du
complexe du discours victimaire des
diasporas et d'acteurs de droits de
l'homisme qui ont imposer la repentance
occidentale comme obligation morale
d'interventionnisme
d'interventionnisme [raclement de gorge]
guerrier pardon excusez-moi j'avais
oublié le moins important justifié à
partir d'une nouble négation on ne peut
pas ne pas elle laisse ouvert le champ
d'application pour les grandes
puissances et après intervention
militaire une situation aussi mauvaise
qu'avant l'intervention ce qu'on se
disait tout à l'heure gage dans
l'issement d'enlisement militaire. Les
forces armées occidentales y entrent à
reculon.
Les élateurs de la guerre civile,
phénomène sous sont nouveaux sont des
sécessionnistes et se diversifient
chaque jour. La dernière version, les
LGBTQA+
et point trois petits points parce que
la liste n'est pas close. Mais cible
directement
le penseur univers le penseur
universaliste. Attends, excuse-moi, je
Oui, mais cible directement.
Le penseur universaliste et désigne un
responsable universel, l'homme blanc,
au pouvoir ou pas, peu importe. Limité
aux grandes démocraties sont divisés en
de multiples sectes qui rivalisent par
la violence de leur discours, professant
un antiracisme raciste. Les les réunions
interdites au blanc dirigé par des
leaders trop proclamés qui refusent
l'élection comme principe politique qui
ni l'universalisme et exclu âgé continu.
Leurs militants sont une sorte de
nouveau SA aux agué contre tout
manquement à leur doxa. servicio
euh non SA au sens les SS, les
prédécesseurs des serviers des SS
puisque c'était eux qui venaient
perturber les trucs de l'opposition.
Donc choisissant sur selon leur propre
critères victimes et bourreaux ils
mènent des campagnes anonymes de haine
sur internet et limitent pour le moment
leur violence matérielle à des statutes.
Voltaire a été tagué.
Donc les penseurs [raclement de gorge]
du complexe militaire ouintellectuel,
souvent universalistes, tentent
désespérément d'accrocher telle ou telle
cause mais l'intersectionnalité supposée
qui les unit contre l'homme blanc les
divise. Pour l'heure, leur discours
n'est encore que théoriste mais s'en
tiendront-ils à des violences
intérieures de basse intensité ? Bon,
j'arrête là, mais c'était pas ça que
j'aurais voulu vous lire, c'est pas
grave.
Comment ça s'appelle le bouquin ?
Le bouquin s'appelle Vendre la guerre,
le complexe militaire intellectuel. En
plus, vous avez droit à ma photo avec.
Vous vous rendez compte ?
[raclement de gorge]
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations avant de nous avoir
donné trois livres à lire ? Écoute, si
j'ai un conseil à donner aux jeunes
générations, c'est voyager, voyager,
voyager, voyager, voyer.
Ils peuvent pas
euh si quand même, il y a un certain
nombre d'espaces qui leur sont ouverts
quand même. Il y a pas que des espaces
fermés, mais je veux dire cette cette
approche de l'autre,
c'est ce qui te relativise véritablement
le confort intellectuel dans lequel tu
te trouves. Tu es dans une société
développée, tu as des protections
sociales, tu as des tas de choses comme
ça. Et donc on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
beaucoup de de choses qui méritent
d'être vécues de près, qui méritent
d'être touché du doigt. [grognement]
Ensuite, pour le reste, on se fera
toujours en fumée, il y a pas de
problème. C'est c'est le principe même
de la propagande, hein. C'est le
principe même du complexe militaire
intellectuel. Donc le témoigner, voyager
et témoigner.
Bon, pour les bouquins, tu me prends un
peu par surprise, mais enfin bon, il y
en a un qui est incontournable, c'est
1984 de George Orwell, essentiel.
Toujours Orwell, il y a le la ferme des
animaux qui explique très bien comment
fonctionne une dictature.
Et puis le troisème,
ben je dis réaliser la fabrication de
l'ennemi. Le mien, c'est le premier que
j'ai écrit il y en a déjà une dizaine
d'années. Mais parce que ça vous
expliquera comment
alors que la guerre est par nature une
inversion des valeurs, on accepte
finalement de tuer, on accepte de
participer à des massacres, on accepte
des tas de choses comme ça. Et donc ça
c'est peut-être la dimension la plus
tragique de notre situation d'homme.
Pierre connaî ça. Merci.
Ben merci à toi. Merci à vous tous les
tous trois là.
[musique]